Guten Morgen, Linus.
Guten Morgen, Tim.
Jetzt wissen alle, dass wir nicht morgens aufnehmen.
Ja, und sie wissen, dass wir doch Hosen anhaben.
Tja, Moll.
Wir haben ja Taschentücher verteilt, weil die Sendung ja traditionell traurig ist. Aber ich würde sagen, das war ein bisschen zu traurig, oder? Das können wir so nicht machen.
Du wolltest immer Moll haben.
Ich wollte immer Moll haben, aber...
Meinst du heute machen wir mal anders?
Heute machen wir nur gute Nachrichten.
Nur gute Nachrichten?
Nur gute Nachrichten.
Wir blicken in die Zukunft und alles wird schön?
Vielleicht ja doch noch. Also es ist ja bei Serien auch so, dass ab der 200. Folge muss auch mal so ein bisschen so der Gedanke kommen, vielleicht gibt es kein Happy End, vielleicht doch, aber irgendwann muss ja der Spannungsbogen.
Na gut, dann probieren wir es nochmal.
Also das hast du davon, wenn du das so machst.
Ja Leute, ey, geil. Also ich bin total beeindruckt von den vielen Leuten, die hierher gekommen sind. Viele bekannte Gesichter, viel unbekannte Gesichter, noch besser. Schön, dass wir euch alle mal kennenlernen. Ganz großes Kino, wir freuen uns und finden es super.
Also wir hätten nie gedacht, dass ihr alle so bescheuert seid, muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen. Aber bevor wir, guck mal, wir haben hier drei ganz unbekannte Gesichter hier. Das möchte ich noch ganz schnell erwähnen, das könnt ihr euch nach der Sendung mal anschauen. Unsere Freunde vom Podcast Technische Aufklärung, die haben ja auch immer die Stella dabei und die Stella zeichnet ja immer die Leute im BND-Untersuchungsausschuss. Und weil ihr das irgendwann zu langweilig wurde, hat sie offenbar gesagt, ich könnte einfach mal aus Fimo die Leute bauen, die da sitzen. Weil niemand hat gesagt, man darf die nur zeichnen. Und es ist faszinierend, was sie da gemacht hat in diese kleine Serie an Figuren, die dann zu Hause gebacken wurden und mit äußerstervorsicht behandelt werden müssen. Aber ich kann euch nur dazu einladen, euch die nachher mal vorsichtig und behutsam anzuschauen.
Sie baden in geschwärzten Aktenunterlagen.
Genau. Sehr hübsch. Super. Aber wir haben tatsächlich gute Nachrichten, Tim. Vielleicht ist das auch eine schlechte Nachricht. Einer der Running Gags aus Logbuch Netzpolitik ist zu Ende. 500 Jahre haben sie uns verfolgt, begleitet, GEMA und die YouTube. Die GEMA und YouTube.
Das stimmt. Die wollten sich immer gegenseitig verklagen und haben das auch mit großer Freude getan und konnten noch überhaupt nicht genug davon kriegen. Ich hatte auch schon das Gefühl, das ist so eine Art Fetisch. Aber irgendwann haben die gemerkt, die Google-Laner mit der GEMA-Peitsche und so, ach ja.
Ja und irgendwann haben die gemerkt, wir wollten gar nicht zum Gericht, sondern wir wollten zum Standesbeamten. Und jetzt sind die verheiratet und haben sich geeinigt, ja.
Das ist ja romantisch.
Es ist geradezu romantisch. Und genau deshalb wollte ich ja auch immer mit Logbuch Netzpolitik auf YouTube. Aber du wolltest nicht.
Ach YouTube, ich bitte dich. Also nee, ist nicht meine Welt. Da sind ja dann die ganze Zeit Kameras auf eingerichtet.
Ja, aber wenn man erstmal wie Tim so investiert ist in Podcasts, dann kann man natürlich jetzt nicht einfach umseilen.
Na ja, jeder soll halt das machen, was man am besten kann. Und ich denke, uns gelingt es halbwegs ordentlich, den Audiokanal zu bespielen. Und dann gibt es halt Leute, die können das halt mit der Kamera viel besser. Und haben da einen flinken Finger mit dem ganzen grafischen Klimbim drum herum. Und schaffen dann auch, sagen wir mal, die kulturkompatible Ansprache.
Ja, Radiogesicht ist glaube ich das Wort.
Danke, du auch.
So, Leute, wir haben Gäste heute.
Genau.
Und zwar alle waren noch nie bei Logbuch Netzpolitik.
Zumindest nicht in der Metaebene.
Also nicht so richtig als Gast. Jetzt feilschen wir nicht um Details.
Wir feilschen nicht um Details, aber sie waren alle noch nicht in der Metaebene und keine volle Sendung bei Logbuch Netzpolitik zu Gast. Und jetzt müssen wir aber trotzdem die Kurve. Jetzt haben wir so schöne YouTube-Einleitungen.
Wolltest du noch mal?
Unser erster Gast. Möchtest du ihn ankündigen oder soll ich?
Kann ich schon machen.
Dann mach mal. Genau.
Wir steigen voll ein auf YouTube und gehen mit der Zeit und begrüßen und wir freuen uns sehr. Raik Anders. Raik, hallo. Komm zu uns auf die Bühne. Dein Applaus. Komm mal hier links. Falscher Sitz. Da möchten wir dich gerne haben. Da sitzt nämlich die Winkelkatze.
Die Katze wollen wir gerne behalten.
Die darfst du auch nicht mitnehmen. Fix das Headset aufgesetzt. Das letzte Mal haben wir unsere Sendung auf dem Camp gemacht und dann haben wir das ohne Headset gemacht. Das wirkte nicht authentisch. Auf jeden Fall. Hallo Raik.
Hallo, hallo.
Touch mal, wer ihn kennt. Was dacht ihr denn schon? Gut gemischt, genau. Weil du hast gar kein Radio-Gesicht. Du bist nämlich richtig im Internet.
Dieses Kompliment, super. Ja, stimmt.
Du machst ein Programm, das heißt Ames Deutschland.
Lügenpresse, Lügenpresse. Das hab ich als erstes gedacht. Als Tim meinte, hier Linus kennst du eigentlich Raik anders, Ames Deutschland. Und dann hast du gedacht, oh nein, jetzt fängt der Tim auch noch an.
Es sind immer die, von denen man das nicht erwartet. Furchtbar.
Aber es geht in deinem Kanal tatsächlich um allerhand Politik. Und ich weiß nicht genommen, hast du dieses Ames Deutschland als Titel genommen, um irgendwie andere Leute anzuziehen und sie da zu missionieren? Oder tut dir Deutschland wirklich leid? Oder kümmert es dich?
Wie stehst du zu Deutschland?
So viele Fragen auf einmal. Entscheidet euch. Es ist eine Mischung aus allem. Also natürlich ist mir Deutschland an sich jetzt nicht komplett egal, weil wenn es mir egal wäre, würde ich mir auch nicht die Zeit nehmen, da so ellenlang auf meinem YouTube-Kanal drüber zu sprechen. Für diejenigen, die gerade nicht geklatscht haben, entweder aus Protest oder weil sie die Sache echt nicht kennen, ich mache einen YouTube-Kanal, in dem ich mich mit Politik beschäftige. Das heißt, ich sitze am Tisch und sage meine Meinung zu den Sachen, die gerade in Deutschland stattfinden. Das kann sehr oft die AfD und Pegida sein, aber auch, was die großen Parteien so treiben. Und der Name Ames Deutschland ist so mein Versuch gewesen, so ein bisschen in die Filterbubble von Leuten vorzudringen, die halt wirklich diese Rhetorik pflegen. Immer ist alles Ames Deutschland und immer ist Lügenpresse und immer ist alles ganz furchtbar. Und ich habe gedacht, wenn Leute vielleicht so auf YouTube sich durchklicken, das sind ja auch Leute, die haben sehr viel Zeit teilweise, und wirklich so auf YouTube sehr lange damit verbringen sich ihre einschlägigen Videos reinzuziehen, dann war so mein Hoffnung ein bisschen, diese Leute vielleicht zu erwischen, dass sie allein aufgrund des bescheuerten Namens draufklicken und anhand der Reaktionen, die man da bekommt, kann ich auf jeden Fall sagen, mission accomplished.
SEO-Optimierung auf andere Weise.
Was kriegst du denn dafür Reaktionen?
Das ist unterschiedlich. Es gibt natürlich zum einen die positiven Reaktionen, wo Leute einfach so ein bisschen den Fanball raushängen lassen und sagen, ich finde deine Sachen so toll. Das ist immer so eine schöne Sache für einen natürlich. Was aber natürlich auch kommt, sind viele Leute, die sich dann auf die Füße getreten fühlen im Sinne von, du darfst aber nicht so schlecht über Frauke Petry reden oder was fällt dir ein? Pegida ist das Beste, was deutscher Niemanns passiert ist. Es ist auf jeden Fall teilweise auch ein bisschen in dieser ekligen Richtung, dass Leute dann wirklich das Gefühl haben, sie müssten jetzt rausfinden, wo du wohnst und wir kriegen dich und was erlaubst du dir? Also in dem Moment wurde den Leuten halt wirklich, also ich unterlege ja meine Videos auch mit Zahlen und Fakten. Es ist nicht so, dass ich einfach nur sage, dass ich einfach so vor der Kamera sitze und sage, ihr seid alle bescheuert. Aber es ist auf jeden Fall auch durchaus mit Informationen unterlegt und wenn du diesen Leuten halt ihr eigenes Weltbild zertrümmerst mit Hilfe von Infos, die du eigentlich in 5 Minuten auf der ersten Seite Google-Sucherergebnisse bekommst, dann fallen diese Leute halt einfach nur noch in so eine aggressive Haltung zurück und dann wird es ungemütlich.
Aber ich könnte mir vorstellen, du hast jetzt auch schon dein Publikum gefunden. Also Leute, die jetzt nicht da einfach nur reingerasselt sind, sondern sowas spricht sich ja auch rum. Wie positioniert sich das sozusagen in diesem ganzen YouTube-Universum? Du hast es da ja mit einer ganz anderen Aufmerksamkeitskonkurrenz zu tun.
Also ist die Frage quasi, wie viel davon wirklich positive oder wirklich Unterstützer sind und wie viel einfach nur so zum Spaß, zum Haten sind, habe ich das richtig verstanden?
Na ja, also wie würdest du dein Publikum charakterisieren? Wir glauben zumindest, ein halbwegs gutes Gefühl dafür zu haben, wer so über Podcasts sich an Themen ranwandt. Das hat ja auch seine Vorteile, die Länge usw. Die hast du ja nicht. Wie lange sind deine Sendungen?
In der Regel so um die 5 bis maximal 10 Minuten.
Genau, kurze Clips.
Aufwendig produziert.
Sehr aufwendig produziert auf jeden Fall.
Das würde ich echt mal interessieren.
Wir haben jetzt so Strichmännchen-Animationen. Wir sind besser geworden auf jeden Fall. Ich kann sagen, seit ich Headlines mache, das ist quasi mein neues Format mit dem SWR zusammen, die sich da gemeinsam mit den Rocket Beans so eingeklingt haben. Seitdem haben wir auch mal einen richtigen Grafiker drangesetzt. Vorher habe ich das immer alles wirklich sehr, sehr schlecht selbst animiert. Jetzt haben wir halt wirklich Leute, die sich darum kümmern und das alles viel schöner machen. Was das Publikum angeht, das fällt mir immer so ein bisschen schwer, das jetzt wirklich, also trotz Facebook-Statistiken oder YouTube-Statistiken, das so wirklich mal in so eine Marketing-Zielgruppe zusammenzufassen. Grundsätzlich kann man sagen, einfach junge Leute vermehrt, sage ich mal so bis 35 oder so, die halt einfach so ein Interesse in sich mittragen und so eine Leidenschaft auch dafür haben und von denen ich auch oft höre, dass sie halt in ihrem eigenen Umfeld, in ihrem eigenen Freundeskreis sich nicht so austauschen können über diese Themen, weil viele Leute haben halt ganz andere Interessenlager. Also da gucken die sich dann jedes Jahr den neuen Fast and Furious an und ansonsten halt wird Party gemacht und dies das. Aber es gibt für diese Leute oft wenige soziale Bezugspunkte, nenne ich mal, wo sie wirklich ihr Interesse für Politik irgendwie unterbringen können. Und das ist auch ganz schön, wenn man es jetzt in den Kommentarspalten bei mir sieht, dass sich da wirklich Freundschaften finden. Es gibt schon Beziehungen, da quasi entstanden auch.
Beziehungen aus YouTube-Kommentarspalten?
Aus Facebook-Kommentaren muss man ehrlich sagen. Da ist ein großer Unterschied. Also das kommt durchaus vor.
Ok, das ist ja schon mal was.
Facebook waren die mit der Volksverhetzung, ne?
Facebook sind die mit dem blauen Logo, ja.
Das ist schon ganz lange her. Wir müssen eigentlich auch immer so ein bisschen die Nachrichten unterbringen. Ich glaube, Mark Zuckerberg, gegen Mark Zuckerberg wird jetzt entwickelt. Der hat, der betreibt dieses Facebook. Entwickelt?
Ermittelt?
Ermittelt wird gegen den, wegen Beihilfe zur Volksverhetzung. Ist es richtig, gegen den zu ermitteln?
Nein, es ist richtig, dass da gerade ermittelt wird. Ich wusste nicht, ob das eine Frage ist.
Und findest du es richtig, dass gegen ihn ermittelt wird?
Ja, ich glaube, das ist eher so ein... Also keine ernsthafte Ermittlung in dem Sinne, dass er jetzt irgendwie für verknackt wird, für sein Facebook, sondern eher so ein Finger zeigen in Richtung Facebook, dass sie jetzt ernst machen sollen mit ihrem Anti-Hate-Speech. Nicht Swat Team, wie haben die das genannt? Action, wie hieß das? Sie haben irgendwie so eine Task Force aufgebaut, zusammen mit den Justizministerien, dass sie da Facebook filtern sollen, wie auch immer. Und dass jetzt gegen ihn persönlich ermittelt wird, halte ich halt für so ein kleines Stück aus der Zauberkiste, im Sinne von wir machen jetzt immer ein bisschen Lärm und Rauch, aber ich glaube jedem ist klar, dass da nicht wirklich ernsthaft was passieren wird.
Ich habe gehört, der zittert schon wie Espen Laub.
Ja, also wahrscheinlich. Da ist er sich in seiner kalifornischen Sonne nicht mehr sicher.
Aber an dir prallt das irgendwie ab. Hast du jetzt nur so Kraft deiner Privilegien als großer weißer Mann? Oder ist dir das egal? Oder lässt du das gar nicht an dich ran? Spielt das nicht so eine große Rolle? Stehen sie schon mit Fackeln und Gabeln vor der Tür?
Ich kriege ja relativ häufig solche Nachrichten, dass Leute mir wirklich drohen und sagen, wir finden dich und wir machen dies und das mit dir und pass auf, wenn du dich umdrehst. Man muss ehrlicherweise dazu sagen, du hast gerade eine wichtige Sache angesprochen. Natürlich kann ich mich jetzt darüber ärgern, dass irgendwelche Nazis sauer auf mich sind, aber ganz ehrlich, wenn ich als dunkelhäutiger Mensch in Deutschland groß geworden wäre, meine beiden besten Freunde, die ich habe, haben beide eine dunkle Hautfarbe, und für die ist das das komplette Leben, wenn die sich auf der Straße bewegen und da kommt eine Gruppe Nazis entgegen, die wissen, dass die scheiß am Dampfen ist. Und die sind ständig auch völlig grundlos, im Gegensatz zu mir sag ich mal, ständig solchen ekelhaften Anfeindungen ausgesetzt, die weit über das hinausgehen, sag ich mal, was mir jetzt meinen persönlichen Alltag irgendwie entgegenschlägt. Und deswegen, solange wir immer noch in einem Land leben, wo das möglich ist einfach, dass Leute aufgrund ihres Aussehens irgendwie so im Fokus stehen von Gewaltanrohungen, von asozialen Menschen. Ich glaube, solange das der Fall ist, hab ich kein Recht mich irgendwie darüber zu beschweren, dass Leute irgendwie mir was antun wollen, weil ihnen meine Meinung nicht passt. Weil wir viele Leute haben, bei denen es einfach nur das Aussehen ist. Und dementsprechend ist es nicht schön, aber ich glaube, ich bin immer noch in einer Position, die nicht vergleichbar ist mit viel anderem.
Du bist ja wahrlich multimedial, schreibst ja sogar Bücher.
Ja, das ist sehr interessant, das hätte ich jetzt vom YouTuber nicht gedacht.
Ja, also mein aktuelles Buch.
Sorry, nein, nein.
Super Titel, Eure Dummheit kotzt mich an.
Dafür hat man doch Applaus verdient. Wenn ein YouTuber ein Buch schreibt, dann kann das auch nur so heißen. Nein, finde ich super.
Geht ja noch weiter.
Eure Dummheit kotzt mir an, wie Bullshit unser Land vergiftet.
Hammer, oder?
Wie viele Seiten hast du da zusammen getragen?
Wahrscheinlich mehr als meine Vorgänger, die vorhin auf die Bühne waren. Also ich habe ein unfassbar schönes Buch von rund 200 Seiten Umfang geschrieben, das seit dem 40. Oktober für 14,90 erhältlich ist. Wer hier gerade bei Amazon surft oder so, der kann gerne zuschlagen. Also es ist ein Buch, da geht es darum zu großen Teilen auch diese ganzen Falschmeldungen, die sich halt durch die sozialen Netzwerke tragen. Ich glaube, jeder hier kennt Mimikama und so viele andere Angebote oder ZDTK und was es da alles gibt. Also diese Fak-Checker-Worksites. Da kommen da teilweise wirklich darsträubende Hokes ans Licht und du hast das Gefühl, es gibt keinerlei Hemmschwelle oder Schamgrenze oder was auch immer, was Leute davon abhält, wirklich die krudesten Theorien im Netz zu verbreiten. Das war auf jeden Fall eine große Inspiration für das Buch. Es geht jetzt nicht nur ums Internet oder um irgendwelche Social-Network-Hokes oder so, aber das war auf jeden Fall eine große Inspiration. Auch die Kommentare dazu von den Leuten, die das wirklich glauben, für dieses Buch. Da haben sich auf jeden Fall eine ganze Menge von kruden Behauptungen versammelt. Auf jeden Fall sehr unterhaltsam.
Also trägst du da jetzt nur solche Fälle zusammen oder hast du da auch so eine kleine Analyse entwickelt, wie man jetzt mit dem ganzen Komplex umgehen muss?
Es ist jetzt nicht nur lustige Beispiele nennen. Dann lachen wir alle gemeinsam drüber, sondern es geht schon darum, wie ist eigentlich die wirkliche Lage und wer profitiert überhaupt von solchen bescheuerten Meldungen und wie kommt das dazu und wie gehen wir als Nutzer damit um, wie geht die Gesellschaft damit um, wie kann das das Klima auch im Land vergiften. Also alles große, große Fragen, die ich als kleiner YouTuber in diesem analogen Medium behandelt habe.
Viel größer als wir, das wollen wir hier nicht wissen.
Naja, das muss man doch alles durch Zehn teilen.
Ja, so ein halbes Ei von Le Floyd ungefähr. Also ich bin jetzt bei 75k und das ist quasi der YouTube-Kanal, aber auch da kann man ruhig mal klatschen.
Hast du schon 200 Sendungen?
Ich glaube, ich habe 122 Videos auf meinem YouTube-Kanal. Also wir sind auf einem guten Weg, irgendwann die 200 voll zu machen.
Aber wo siehst du denn jetzt... Jetzt muss ich auch mal ein bisschen die Medienfrage stellen. Also wo siehst du denn so die Vorteile und die Kraft für, sagen wir mal, doch mit dem, was wir zum Beispiel machen, vergleichbaren Vermittlungsansatz? Also wo denkst du, spielt das Medium wirklich eine große Rolle? Ist das jetzt nur so dieses, weil da alle sowieso sind? Oder denkst du, dass man damit auch bewusst was herbeiführen kann?
Also ich will da euch auch gar nicht vor den Karren fahren, im Sinne von, weil da halt alle so dabei sind. Ich finde, es ist tatsächlich wichtig, dass wenn man halt Themen in die Öffentlichkeit tragen will, dass man auch die Leute da abholt, wo sie sind. Also das ist ja meiner Meinung nach auch immer so ein ganz großes Problem von vielen Linken irgendwie aus meiner Sicht, dass sie immer den direkten Kontakt, was heißt nicht scheuen, aber vielleicht so ein bisschen verschoben wahrnehmen. Weil ich finde, du kannst jetzt von der jungen Generation nicht erwarten, dass sie irgendwie dein Fazleitartikel lesen oder sowas. Oder dass sie jetzt komplett sich auch vielleicht die Zeit nehmen für so einen mehrstündigen Podcast oder was auch immer. Deswegen alles hat seine Berechtigung, die verschiedenen Vermittlungsformen, die es da gibt. Und jeder wird auch sein Publikum finden. Ich sehe mich ja auch nicht als der Weisheit letzter Schluss. Also ich verstehe mein Format und meinen YouTube-Kanal oder auch meine Facebook-Seite immer als so ein Einstieg für Leute, die sonst vielleicht nicht in Berührung gekommen wären mit dem Thema. Und daraus dann vielleicht so ihre eigene Vorliebe, ihre eigene Leidenschaft irgendwie dafür finden. Das sind auch Rückmeldungen, die ich ab und zu mal bekomme, wenn mir dann irgendwelche 14-Jährigen vielleicht mal schreiben, hey, ich hab mich früher nie dafür interessiert, aber ich hab mir jetzt, so blöd das klingt, halt die Spiegel-Online-App mal runtergeladen. Oder ich lese jetzt mal die Zeitung von meinem Vater irgendwie mit. So, das sind so diese kleinen Erfolgsmeldungen. Weil ich finde, es ist immer noch, also man kann nicht voraussetzen oder erwarten, dass jetzt alle total interessiert sind sofort, sondern es muss immer irgendjemand geben, das wird bei euch genauso gewesen sein, der bei euch irgendwie dafür gesorgt hat, dass ihr das spannend fandet, dass ihr euch da irgendwie einbringen wolltet. Es wird immer ein Vorbild geben oder eine Projektionsfläche oder was auch immer. Und dementsprechend sollte man, meine Meinung nach, auch gar nicht das so behandeln im Sinne von, ah, die Plattform gefällt mir nicht.
Du hast dich aber trotzdem irgendwie, sage ich mal, bewusst für diese Plattform entschieden. Oder hat die Plattform dich gefunden? Das ist ja auch so ein bisschen so das Ding. Ich meine, die sind ja, wie gesagt, die sind sehr gut, diese YouTube-Videos. Wird man dazu geboren? Oder hast du einen Style, den du dir durchdenkst? Oder ist das einfach deiner? Das klingt jetzt fast so, als hättest du den Plan gehabt. Moment, irgendwas leuchtet grundlegend schief. Ich muss jetzt irgendwie auf YouTube mir genau die Leute schnappen, bei denen man das Ruder noch rumreißen kann. Das klingt jetzt fast so, als hättest du das irgendwie...
Also ganz am Anfang meiner unglaublichen Mission, sage ich mal, stand tatsächlich die Angst... Ich formuliere so, ich habe schon früher auf meinem privaten Facebook-Profil, so vor 3, 4 Jahren, habe ich auch schon politische Sachen kommentiert, so kleine Beiträge, wo ich ein bisschen was dazu geschrieben habe oder auch mein lustiges Bildchen. Und das habe ich dann halt so auf meinem 200-Freunde-Profil irgendwie gemacht. Und irgendwann hatte ich Angst, dass mir einfach alle Freunde entfolgen, weil sich halt wirklich niemand dafür interessiert hat. Also es ist halt, Politik war halt auf Facebook jetzt nicht so der große Bringer, sag ich mal, zu dem Zeitpunkt. Da ging es um diese lustigen T-Videos und wir pranken uns alle gegenseitig, hahaha, und geile Autos. Und irgendwie, es hat keinen wirklich interessiert, deswegen habe ich gedacht, ok, bevor ich das an meine Freunde verliere, mache ich das auf einer gesonderten Seite. Und wem es gefällt, der kann das abonnieren. Und dann war es halt auch erstmal so ein langer Weg, dass man aus seiner eigenen Freundesblase dann so rausgekommen ist, weil am Anfang, vielleicht sind ja auch Facebook-Seitenbetreiber im Raum, am Anfang gibst du Leute, die deine Seite einfach so aus Mitlike liken, weil die finden, du bist das Mensch echt okay. Mitlike. Ja, Mitlike. Das waren diese Mitlikes, die da gekommen sind. Und irgendwann, glücklicherweise, hat sich das so ein bisschen dahin bewegt, dass halt viele Leute auf die Seite gekommen sind durch die Sachen, die ich gemacht hab. Und dann ging es von da ab immer bergab. Aber ich finde auf jeden Fall Mitlike ist das Wort, was ich heute aus dieser Mannstattung mitnehme.
Was sind denn die Themen, die die Trollen oder die Hater am meisten reizen? Vielleicht können wir da ja ein bisschen mehr auch bei uns eingehen. Also die letzte Sendung, die ich von dir gesehen hab, das war diese, war das Bahn-Württemberg, Demo für alle? Da hat sich irgendwie jemand gedacht, wär doch vielleicht gar nicht so verkehrt, wenn wir im Zuge der Vorbereitung unserer Kinder auf das zukünftige Leben Ihnen irgendwann früher oder später mal die Tatsache offenbaren, dass es nicht nur Heterosexualität gibt. Dann war Baden-Württemberg in Not.
Es hat gebrannt.
Da sind Leute aufgestanden, von denen hat man gedacht, dass sie längst tot waren. Du setzt dich dann hin und haust auf den Tisch. Was passiert? Kommen dann die Leute und sagen, du bist aber bestimmt auch schwul oder du warst früher eine Frau. Welches Thema reizt die Leute mehr?
Das ist natürlich auch immer eine Sache. Sobald du dich für Schwule, Lesben, Trans oder Intersexuelle einsetzt, bist du natürlich automatisch selber schwul. Von wegen, selber Schwucht oder was erlaubst du dir? So weißt du, ob man schwul sein müsste, um sich für die Rechte von den Leuten stark zu machen. Ich muss auch kein Baum sein, um gegen die Abholzung des Regenwalds zu sein. Was da in Baden-Württemberg passiert ist, ich weiß nicht, es ist sehr komisch alles. Ich glaube, Klaus Wohlbreit wünsche sich, er wäre tot, damit er in seinem Grab rotieren kann. Es ist wirklich einfach nur unfassbar, was da abläuft. Es gibt einfach nur einen Lehrplan für Hessen, wo es darum geht, dass wir akzeptieren, dass es nicht nur den einen Lebensentwurf mit Mann, Frau, Familie, Ehe gibt, sondern in der heutigen Zeit verschiedene. Die Leute sehen das sehr kritisch und schlimm. Natürlich prasselt dann auch auf mich der Shitstorm sofort wieder los. Ich wurde vorhin gefragt, ob ich mal einen Shitstorm erlebt hätte. Bei mir ist es so, jede Woche, ja. Das ist so ein regelmäßiges Programm bei mir. Aber die allermeisten Anfeindungen kommen eigentlich immer dann, wenn es um den Islam geht. Wenn ich zum Beispiel nach einem Terroranschlag die Frechheit besitze. Darauf hinzuweisen, dass nicht alle uns liegen müssen. Also diese totalen Binsen-Weisheiten eigentlich. Aber trotzdem darauf reagieren die Leute wirklich am angepisstesten. Und natürlich jedes Mal, wenn es um die AfD und Pegida geht. Die großen Hitbringer, sag ich mal, was Shitstorms angeht.
Deine Zeit ist leider begrenzt. Eine Sache vielleicht noch, die fiel mir gerade noch ein. Du erinnerst dich, und du auch, vor ein paar Jahren, da hatten wir diese ACTA-Geschichte. Da stand so ACTA zur Diskussion. Und wir saßen schon wieder so in Podcasts und so, na ja, das wird dann halt wieder so beschlossen. Und wie das immer so ist. Und wir mit unseren kleinen netzpolitischen Fahnen-Schwenkern und so. Und dann ging das ja irgendwie in Polen irgendwie los. Und auch hier in Berlin gab es so eine riesige Demo. Ich war auf dieser Demo, wo normalerweise halt immer so die üblichen Verdächtigen da ihre Wimpelchen schwingen.
War das diese freiheitliche Angst-Demo?
Nee, das war nicht freiheitliche Angst-Demo, das war explizit eine Demo gegen diese ACTA-Geschichte.
Waren aber die gleichen Leute.
So, aber auf einmal war halt alles voll mit, ich sag mal, so YouTube-Publikum. Also ohne das jetzt herab, es ist keine herablassende Feststellung, sondern sozusagen Leute, die einfach ganz offensichtlich nicht so zum typischen netzpolitischen Kulturkreis gehören. Und auf einmal war das in YouTube so a thing. So nach dem Motto, die wollen uns das Internet wegnehmen.
Also was der Tim fragen will, kannst du das nochmal für uns machen.
Nein, ich will sagen, warum passiert das so selten? Also warum passiert das jetzt nicht bei sowas wie BND-Gesetz und so weiter? Ist das, weil das zu trocken ist? Muss man immer nur drohen, die schalten euch das Internet ab oder lassen euch die Filme nicht mehr runterladen? Wie kann man dieses Mobilisierungspotential an der Stelle nutzen? Oder gibt es überhaupt eins?
Guck mal, die ganz deprimierende Antwort darauf ist wahrscheinlich, dass ich selber keine Ahnung hab, was da noch passieren müsste, damit die Leute mal aus dem Arsch kommen. Also es ist ja unfassbar, was sich da abspielt. Und gerade im Zug dieser ganzen BND-NSA-Affäre, sage ich mal, ich weiß nicht, wie das noch in irgendeiner Form und Weise asoziale oder krasser hätte kommen können. Und trotzdem ist der absolute Großteil der Bevölkerung komplett zufrieden auf seinem Arsch sitzen geblieben und hat nicht im Geringsten das Gefühl gehabt, dass da irgendwas falsch läuft. Also es ist vielleicht wirklich die blöde alte Erklärung, dass solange man nicht tatsächlich selber den Spion irgendwie bei sich im Badezimmer hat, dass solange noch alles okay ist. Und natürlich wird da auch die Terrorangst noch mit reinspielen, dass manche Leute dann das Gefühl haben, ja, ist ja berechtigt. Und ich meine, das Allerdümsste ist ja wirklich noch dieses Argument, ja, ich hab ja nichts zu verstecken, also da hört immer alles auf irgendwie. Also da könnte ich mir wirklich selbst in die Fresse hauen, wenn ich das höre. Jetzt noch ein positives Ende. Ein positives Ende quasi. Ich hoffe halt wirklich, wenn von der jüngeren Generation vielleicht noch mal Leute nachkommen und die jetzt auch das Gefühl haben, dass sie vielleicht auch inspiriert durch Sachen wie das, was ihr macht. Vielleicht auch denken, hey, hier läuft so gewaltig was schief, ich muss mich da einbringen. Dass wir da vielleicht wirklich zukünftig irgendwelche Leute auch in der Politik oder in Verbänden auf unserer Seite haben, sag ich mal. Und deswegen ist es auch eine ganz wichtige Arbeit, was ihr macht. So, dass ihr halt einfach wirklich die Öffentlichkeit einfach schafft. Und auch wenn es eine kleine Öffentlichkeit ist. Ich meine, guck dir die Piratenpartei an. Von früher, sag ich mal. Das war ein, ja, ich will jetzt nicht, dass du, aber pass auf, pass auf. Ich finde trotzdem, dass die an der ganzen Akta-Geschichte, sag ich mal, im Europäischen Parlament auch durchaus mit ihren wenigen Abgeordneten, die sie hatten, trotzdem mitgeholfen haben, dass da einfach was in Bewegung gerät. Ich rede jetzt nicht davon, dass die Piratenpartei auf einmal zurückkommt, irgendwie von den Toten aufersteht und sagt, hier sind wir. Und das muss auch gar keine einzelne Partei sein, sondern einfach, dass man es irgendwie schafft, Leute dafür zu begeistern und ihnen auch klar zu machen, wie wichtig das ist. Und dass sie dann vielleicht, sag ich mal, in unser anderen Namen, so das wäre jetzt natürlich die maximale Naivität, die da aus mir spricht, aber dass sie trotzdem dann eines Tages, das wird jetzt nicht morgen sein, das wird auch nicht in zwei Jahren sein, aber dann hoffentlich in Zukunft dafür sorgt, dass so ein Scheiß wieder zurückgenommen wird, dass so etwas nicht weiter verfolgt wird. Und es sind alles nur Gesetze, die irgendwie dem Zeitgeist unterliegen. Das heißt, wenn irgendwann wieder Leute am Drücker sind, die vielleicht ein bisschen mehr von der Materie verstehen oder ein anderes, ein anderweitig gewachsenes Rückgrat besitzen, dass man dann vielleicht so einen Schwachsten auch wieder rückgängig machen kann. Aber ich hab leider auch keinen Zauberstab, mit dem ich sagen kann, so, hier ist die Lösung für alles und wenn ich ein YouTube-Video mache, dann ist auf einmal die Welt wieder in Ordnung. Das klappt leider nicht.
Aber du bleibst auf der Suche nach diesem Video.
Ruf uns an, wenn es so weit ist. Danke anders. Vielen Dank. Hat mich echt gefreut.
Danke dir. Ja, so viel zum Thema YouTube. Wir haben ja gesagt, heute gibt es nur gute Nachrichten oder nur positives.
Also wir wollen in die Zukunft blicken und mal ein bisschen auch versuchen, zu einzunorden, was man eigentlich schaffen kann und nicht immer nur dieses, ne?
Also es ist auch so ein bisschen selbsterhalt, ne? Also ich meine, es kann eigentlich nicht mehr beschissener kommen. Und wenn wir Pech haben, ist das Thema irgendwann vorbei. Also Netzpolitik als Thema, da müssen wir was anderes machen. Logbuch, was auch immer dann noch nicht verkackt ist.
Zweite Bundesliga.
Logbuch zweite Bundesliga, ja. Wobei das sieht gerade auch so aus, als würde St. Pauli da dauerhaft... Also wir brauchen ja irgendwie... das Themenfeld muss ja weiterleben.
Das despolitische Themenfeld muss weiterlesen.
Damit wir darüber labern können. Und damit wir darüber labern können, brauchen wir ja auch Leute, die tatsächlich was machen. Und da haben wir uns überlegt, da laden wir uns mal einen Gast ein, der im politischen Betrieb seit langer Zeit an der guten Sache tätig ist und bemüht ist und da auch Erfolge feiert. Weil uns aufgefallen ist, dass wir sowas eigentlich selten in der Sendung haben. Deswegen begrüßen wir Maria Reimer.
Hallo, Maria.
Maria, du hast im politischen Betrieb viel getan, bei Transparency International. Du hast als politische, ne, wie heißt das denn, wissenschaftliche Mitarbeiterin einer Bundestagsabgeordneten gearbeitet. Du bist jetzt bei der Open Knowledge Foundation, machst da so schöne Projekte wie Jugendhackt und hattest irgendwo auch die Finger im Spiel als fragt den Staat gegründet wurde. Also immer so das Positive, ja, in einer Welt des Negativen. So, Tim und ich sitzen da, erzählen den ganzen Tag schlechte Nachrichten und du arbeitest an einer besseren Welt.
So hätte ich mein Leben auch beschrieben.
Ein Träumchen.
Und da drängen sich natürlich zwei Fragen auf. Erstens, wie behält man da den Mut? Und wie schafft man diesen Erfolg in diesem politischen Bereich? Was hast du gelernt, was wir noch nicht gelernt haben?
Ja, und wie kommst du da überhaupt alles dazu? Das würde mich ja auch mal interessieren. Was erlaube?
Jetzt haben wir zu viele Fragen.
Ich fange mit Tims an, weil die einfacher zu beantworten ist. Also alles fing an mit einem total gut aussehenden Philosophielehrer in der Schule und ich hab gedacht, dass was der macht, das lohnt sich mal anzuhören. Na also, keine Ahnung.
Der hatte kein Radiogesicht.
Der hatte definitiv kein Radiogesicht. Und irgendwie habe ich gemerkt, so die ganzen politischen Dinge interessieren mich. Ich hab dann Politikwissenschaft studiert und zwischendurch hatte ich gar keine Lust mehr zu studieren und hab ein Praktikum bei Transparency Deutschland gemacht. Also dem deutschen Büro dieser großen Antikorruptionsorganisation Transparency International. Und da hab ich offen gestanden super viel gelernt. Also man wütet ja immer so über Praktika und irgendwie die Leute werden so ausgebeutet, aber wenn man sich halt irgendwo einen Ort sucht, wo man vielleicht minimal bezahlt wird und Transparency hat für damalige Verhältnisse super ordentlich bezahlt, dafür, dass ich quasi keine abgeschlossene Ausbildung hatte. Und ich hab halt dort einfach super viel gelernt. Und eine der Sachen, die ich gelernt hab, war, dass es sich immer lohnt, sich zu engagieren, auch wenn man nicht sieht, dass es einen unmittelbaren Effekt haben könnte. Also ich muss dazu ganz kurz ausholen, also Transparency Deutschland ist keine Hippie-Organisation nie gewesen, sondern es wurde halt gegründet von einem ehemaligen Direktor der Weltbank, Peter Eigen, der genau in Afrika dafür verantwortlich war, die Gelder der Weltbank sozusagen zu investieren und Krankenhäuser zu bauen und seine Ehefrau war Ärztin und fand sich auf der anderen Seite der Mauer wieder, als er dann irgendwie diese Gelder in Gebäude verwandeln wollte und sie dann halt abends am Abendbrottisch gesagt hat, ja, Peter, da steht aber kein Krankenhaus, wo ist denn die ganze Kohle hin? So und dann hat er das so ein bisschen intern verfolgt und hat sich dann so ein Memorandum eingefangen und hat das dann aber weiter verfolgt und haben sie ihm gesagt, so können wir mit euch nicht mehr arbeiten, Ich hab danach gesagt, okay dann kündige ich eben und gründe Transparency Deutschland. Und das war also sozusagen immer eine Organisation von ziemlich beruflich erfolgreichen, honorigen Männern und Frauen, die einfach komplett wussten, wie der politische Laden läuft. Das waren Juristen, sind Verwaltungswissenschaftler, also einfach Menschen, die auch eher am Ende des Berufslebens stehen oder zumindest mittendrin. Und von denen konnte ich halt als junge Studentin irgendwie super viel lernen. Und eine der Sachen, die ich halt gelernt habe und wo ich gemerkt habe, als ich die Einladung von euch bekommen habe, habe ich mich so gefragt, was kann ich hier eigentlich überhaupt beitragen? Und da ist mir das eingefallen, dass eine der Sachen, die mich eigentlich heute unbewusst noch leiten, ich dort gelernt habe von Michael Wien, dem damaligen Chef von Peter Eigen, der gesagt hat, okay, wenn ich pensioniert werde, dann mach ich auch bei Transparency mit. Und ich habe ihn dann gefragt, wie sind sie darauf gekommen und glauben sie denn, dass Korruption durch ihr Engagement weniger wird? Und hat er gelacht und hat gesagt, nein, natürlich nicht, aber es wäre total dumm, es nicht zu versuchen, Korruption so teuer wie möglich zu machen. Und das fand ich ziemlich nice.
Teuer wie möglich, also er wollte die Preise nach oben zeigen.
Genau, also er wollte es einfach teuer machen.
Also wenn ihr schon scheiße seid, müsst ihr euch zumindest ordentlich anstrengen.
Genau, es muss halt einfach wehtun.
Und die wussten dadurch ihre Erfahrung, wo der Hase lang läuft, quasi. Wussten, wie die Korruption überhaupt stattfindet und konnten das deswegen bekämpfen.
Genau, sie hatten sozusagen, sie saßen halt selber an den Schaltstellen und hatten halt alles gesehen und konnten deswegen, als sie dann rausgegangen sind, identifizieren, wo es überhaupt Schnittstellen gibt, wo man halt einhaken kann, welche Punkte auch wehtun und wo Gelegenheitsfenster sind. Eine weitere Sache, die ich bei Transparency gelernt habe, was ich glaube, was auch so Schlachtschiffe wie solche sehr analogen Organisationen irgendwie immer noch sehr effektiv machen. Die schlagen halt zu, wenn sie ein Gelegenheitsfenster sehen und nicht klicken, irgendwie nicht wild like und sind dann enttäuscht, dass nichts passiert, sondern die analysieren halt irgendwie relativ souverän die Lage und sagen, okay, da haben wir eine Gelegenheit und da geben wir jetzt halt rein.
Das versuchen wir ja auch.
Ihr macht das super. Ihr gebt zum Beispiel auch nicht auf, also.
Wir versuchen das so teuer wie möglich zu machen.
Aber wenn du sagst, wir haben Organisationen von innen gesehen und wissen, wie die arbeiten, das trifft ja bei uns ein bisschen zu auf den politischen Betrieb. Wir würden den gerne beeinflussen, wir brauchen Leute, die uns erklären, wie der von innen funktioniert, damit man auch weiß, wie schafft man denn es überhaupt auf diesen politischen Betrieb Einfluss zu nehmen. Also wie findet man Gehör? Offenbar gibt es ja das Mittel der Demonstration, dass es das letzte Mal wirklich einen wirklich fetten Einfluss erlangt hat, ist irgendwie ein bisschen länger her. Trotzdem wird Politik jeden Tag gemacht und ja auch nicht ohne, dass andere Leute darauf Einfluss nehmen. Was uns also interessieren würde als ehemalige Mitarbeiterin im Deutschen Bundestag, wie bekommt man denn da Gehör? Wie können wir denn da mal irgendwie Einfluss nehmen?
Ja, ich habe da mal recherchiert und extra, weil ich wusste, dass ihr irgendwann 200 Jahre Netzpolitik feiert und bin den Bundestag gegangen dafür und habe für euch recherchiert und, nee Scherz, also ich habe zwei Jahre als wissenschaftliche Mitarbeiterin gearbeitet für Tabea Rössner, die ist grüne Abgeordnete. Ich habe selber kein Parteibuch, aber ich fand die ziemlich gut, deswegen habe ich gedacht, ich nutze das mal, um sie zu erwähnen. Ich mochte sie sehr gerne, hat irgendwie gute Arbeit und gute Dinge getan und weil wir halt leider nicht alle selber Abgeordnete werden können, was wir wahrscheinlich eigentlich wollten, weil da hat man tatsächlich ziemlich viel Einfluss, auch wenn man Opposition der Opposition angehört, habe ich gedacht, also als zivilgesellschaftlicher Akteur kann man eigentlich zwei Dinge hervorragend machen. Das habe ich so gemerkt an der täglichen Arbeit, wenn wir also Themen auf den Tisch bekommen haben und auf einmal Not hatten, Zeitnot und inhaltliche Not, weil du bist ja hochreaktiv unterwegs. Also ihr oder wir jetzt bei Jugendhack, wir stehen halt morgens auf und denken uns so, denken uns aus, was wir halt gerne den lieben langen Tag machen würden und machen das dann einfach. Also das ist zumindest ein bisschen bei Jugendhack so. Aber parlamentarische Arbeiten ist halt super hochreaktiv, also du kriegst halt irgendeine Gesetzesvorlage und dann musst du schnell dazu eine Position haben und du hast aber keine, weil du bist Generalist und selten Spezialist für irgendein Thema. Vor allem, weil das ja das Wesen von Politik ist, es kommen halt ständig neue Themen auf, die gesetzlich geregelt werden sollen und nur weil du gerade Abgeordnete bist, weißt du ja nicht notwendigerweise, was zu tun ist. Also hast du Stress und du suchst eigentlich zwei Sachen. Erstens Blogs, die in einigermaßen korrekter Rechtschreibung verfasst sind, die du zitieren und wo du im Impressum nachschlagen kannst und die Leute anrufen kannst und sagen kannst, hier ihr seid Experte, zu was völlig abwägen, keine Ahnung. Ich hatte, als ich noch da gearbeitet habe, musste ich mich auseinandersetzen mit der Entzündlichkeit von Nitrat-Filmen. Also hier Thema Stummfilmkino. Das war irgendwie genau und da gab es dann irgendwie kleine Anfrage und großes Drama und das Bundesarchiv verbrennt Filme, also die Originalfilme. Das Thema war Filmerbe, also wie konservieren wir das? Und auf einmal musste ich halt irgendjemand finden, der aussagefähig ist zum Verbrennungsgrad von Nitrat-Filmen.
Und da gibt es Blogs?
Ja, und da gibt es halt einfach zwei Leute in Deutschland, deren Hobby das ist und die schreiben Gott sei dank drüber.
Was die Filme oder die Entzündlichkeit dieser Filme?
Verbrennen den ganzen Tag Film und schreiben Blog drüber.
Also so wie methodisch inkorrekt nur mit Film. Ne genau, die sind halt einfach irgendwie Film-Nerds oder Nitrat-Nerds, keine Ahnung. Auf jeden Fall haben sie mir meine Fragen beantworten können und das war super und sie sind halt auch glaube ich genständig und das ist der zweite Punkt, als Sachverständige im Bundestag ein und aus, wenn genau solche Spezialthemen verhandelt werden. Also nicht erst seitdem du sie gefragt hast, sondern, nee genau, weil dieses Thema Filmerbe jetzt ja natürlich nicht einfach nur dieser Legislatur aufgetaucht ist, sondern ja immer mal wieder Phases.
Aber du hast sie über die Blogs gefunden und nicht über ihre Tätigkeit beim Bundestag, das war sozusagen anders.
Ja genau, also kann natürlich auch in meiner modernen Recherche liegen oder so, aber genau, aber das wäre sozusagen die eine Botschaft, also macht keine Podcast, schreibt Texte, also Bundestag ist halt einfach...
Der ist auch immer im Bundestag hier, das geht schon.
Genau, also genau, ist halt auf jeden Fall eine Textbranche, also egal wie abwegig, wie abwegige Interessen man hat, also schreibt auf, zum Beispiel Netzpolitik relativ abwegig, also schreibt halt drüber und lasst euch dann im zweiten Schritt als Sachverständige einladen, also Gesetzesinitiativen werden immer durch Sachverständigen Anhörungen begleitet, du kennst das ja gut und da hat man gute Chancen, sich einladen zu lassen und so die Dinge.
Dann muss man kurz Podcasts machen. Genau. Aber dann kommen wir noch zum letzten Themenfeld, also ich sehe da so ein Wandel aus der Politik raus, jetzt irgendwie ins selber machen, ja in einer NGO quasi, das Ruder selbst in die Hand zu nehmen, jetzt machen wir mal hier konkrete Projekte, Initiativen, Jugendhackt ist enorm gewachsen in, ich glaube fünf Jahren oder was ist das jetzt?
In 2013 hat es angefangen, also vier Jahre.
Vier Jahre Jugendhackt, irgendwie von einer Veranstaltung pro Jahr auf, weiß ich nicht, wie viele sind es jetzt?
Dies Jahr acht.
Das sind aber drei Jahre von 2013.
Das ist korrekt, aber wir haben schon das vierte Jugendhackt jetzt durchgeführt.
Achso, okay, verstehe.
Da ist der Tim immer ganz speziell. So wenn du sagst fünf Jahre.
Faktchecking, jetzt auch in Podcasts.
Das ist mit dem Post faktisch irgendwie noch nicht mitgekriegt. Wir haben beide recht.
Wie kam die Idee zur Jugendhackt? Es gibt ja offenbar irgendwie einen Bedarf. Habt ihr da gesessen, habt überlegt, was ist der Bedarf? Nein. Also ihr habt wahrscheinlich irgendwie den Bedarf selber gespürt.
Genau, also die erste Überlegung war, es müsste so was wie Jugendhackt eigentlich geben. Es gibt Jugendforscht, Jugendmusiziert, Jugend schreibt. Also es gibt alle möglichen lustigen Jugendveranstaltungen in Deutschland, aber es gibt keinen Jugendhackt und irgendwie ist der Name bei irgendeinem Brandstorming hängen geblieben und ich und ein paar andere Leute hatten halt sofort eine Idee davon, was das dann sein würde. So und dann haben wir halt eine erste Pilotveranstaltung gemacht und wurden total überrannt. Also ein befreundeter Medienpädagoge meinte damals zu, ja Maria ist irgendwie ein gutes Konzept, aber wenn da 20 kommen, dann wird es eine gute Veranstaltung und ich war halt super enttäuscht, weil ich dachte, ne für 20 mach ich das nicht, das ist mir irgendwie viel zu aufwendig. Minderjährige, da musst du die Elternzettel einsammeln und so, das ist echt ein anderer Schnack, Sachen für unter 18-Jährige zu organisieren. Und dann haben sich ohne Werbung, weil quasi keine Mittel, 80 Jugendliche angemeldet und wir konnten nur 60 nehmen, weil wir überhaupt Ressourcen für 60 Plätze hatten und dann war uns klar, okay, der Bedarf ist offensichtlich da und Hackertum ist halt irgendwie nicht eine Referenz an eine Subkultur aus den 80ern oder so, sondern das ist offenbar lebendig so und…
Und auch nicht kriminell konnotiert, was ja eigentlich auch lange Zeit so der Verdacht war.
Also zumindest nicht so sehr bei den Jugendlichen. In den ersten Jahren haben wir tatsächlich Anrufe von Eltern bekommen, was in der Art passiert. Die Anrufe haben wir auf jeden Fall abgenommen. Also das ist auf jeden Fall der kleine Effekt so, also in der Blase, in der wir uns mit Jugend hacken bewegen, fragt keiner mehr nach, wie wir hacken definieren.
Okay, das ist schon ganz gut. Also hab ich schon lange darauf gewartet, dass so dieser kriminelle Unterton beim Wort hacken wegfällt und dass es irgendwie so ein bisschen dann auch tatsächlich geschehen.
Hurra!
Bei uns find's ganz cool.
Dein schönstes Erlebnis bei Jugendhackt?
Das gehört zu jeder Show.
So eine Frage.
Ihr habt doch gar keine Übung mit positiven Fragen. Oh Mann. Jetzt hätte ich was vorbereiten sollen.
Kannst du auch so ganz generell beantworten. Also was ist das, was du da persönlich am meisten rausziehst? Also ist es so die Reaktion der Leute oder die verrückten Ideen?
Na die Jugendlichen haben halt Bock auf Lernen. Die haben halt Bock aufeinander. Die haben halt dieses Klischee des Kinderzimmerprogrammierers, der irgendwie selbst gewählt die Einsamkeit sucht, weil da stört ihn keiner. Das ist halt ein totaler Mythos.
Am Heimcomputer sitze ich hier, Programmier die Zukunft mir. Die haben es schon in den 70ern begriffen.
Also vielleicht so ein bisschen notgedrungen in dieser Alterskohorte, weil sie halt einfach durch Schule relativ gebunden sind und jetzt irgendwie nicht immer ewig weit fahren können, um sozusagen offline physisch Gleichgesinnte zu treffen. Das ist ja auch einer der Sachen, warum wir Jugendhack machen, dass sie sich halt endlich mal sehen. Aber wir haben das halt auch mal wissenschaftlich evaluiert und die Jugendlichen haben halt nach Jugendhack signifikant mehr Lust, gemeinsam zu programmieren. Also das ist halt einfach eine Frage des Erlebnisses. In dem Moment, wo du quasi Gleichgesinnte hast, geht es eher alles einfacher. Ist eher alles fein, genau. Also das macht halt total Laune. Die haben halt Lust auf Lernen und Lust aufeinander und Lust auf irgendwie die Grenzen in ihren Köpfen zu sprengen. Und der schönste, also mein schönstes Erlebnis bei Jugendhackt ist alljährlich der Satz, endlich normale Leute hier. Der fällt immer. Ich weiß immer nicht, ob das Leute vorher irgendwo gelesen haben, das deswegen zitiert. Aber das irgendwie, genau, es kommen ja auch immer neue Kinder und Jugendliche und neue Mentoren und Mentorinnen zu uns. Und irgendwer sagt den Satz immer an diesen Wochenenden, endlich normale Leute. Und das ist auch ziemlich cool.
Ja, das ist wirklich super.
So wie heute Abend hier übrigens.
Genau, Maria.
Bevor ihr mich raus schmeißt, ihr habt ja Geburtstag. Ich schenke euch noch was.
Ah, das wollte ich haben.
Du weißt es schon, oh Mann.
Ich weiß nix.
Genau, ihr kennt ja Frag den Staat. Das ist auch ein Programm der Open Knowledge Foundation, die auch Jugendhack trägt, zusammen mit Mediale Pfade. Und Frag den Staat hat ein neues Band-2-T-Shirt. Verklagt den Staat mit den nächsten Stationen. Hier 2.17, VG Berlin, VG Köln, Bundesverfassungsgericht Karlsruhe.
Das ist übrigens ein, also das Shirt ist besonders geil. Man sieht hier so in so einem Kiss-Design mit Paragrafenzeichen ins Gesicht gemalt. Errare, Gubernatorni, Est-Tour 2016, Verklagt den Staat. Wir freuen uns und das Design hat übrigens... Da reden wir nachher nochmal drüber.
Da reden wir nachher nochmal drüber.
Wohlwollend geschätzt und mir wurde gesagt, die fallen klein aus.
Wohlwollend geschätzt.
Danke. Ich glaube, deine Zeit ist dann jetzt auch vorbei.
Maria Reimer, vielen Dank. Danke.
Ich nutze mal eben die Unruhe hier im Saal und angeblich wäre der Stream zu leise, da ist der Twitter sich am aufregen ganz bitter böse.
Ja, da kann man aber nichts dran drehen, da müsste die Experten da oben fragen.
Und da sind die Experten, da gehe ich gleich hin. Und dann sollst du bitte nochmal aufstehen, damit die Leute sehen können, was auf deinem T-Shirt drauf steht. Also da sind schon mehrere Tweets gekommen, die wollen, da steht Chaos Computer Camp drauf. Entschuldige bitte, ist wirklich, wollten die Leute...
Wer Chaos Computer Camp sagt, der geht raus.
Uni...
Weiter machen, danke.
Ion Camp, das ist das Alternative Camp Design von Gregor Seelag.
Der da vorne sitzt. Ihr könnt auch beglückwünschen, tolles Ding. Ich hab leider keins abbekommen.
Und das ist, ich wollte dich noch kurz erzählen, warum ich das kenne. Das hat nämlich Roland gezeichnet und Roland zeichnet gerade auch da oben und er hat gesagt, er macht nicht so viele Witze über uns, aber manchmal höre ich euch lachen, das heißt, ich weiß, dass er Witze macht.
Das hatte ich schon ganz vergessen da oben.
Ja, in der Sorge um unsere Zukunft haben wir jetzt gesprochen, YouTube schon besetzt, politische Arbeit haben wir ein bisschen gelernt, wie wir da vielleicht Einfluss nehmen können.
Ja, die sind alle so engagiert. Wir lesen ja nur Meldungen vor.
Genau, das Wichtigste für Logbuch Netzpolitik sind tatsächlich Leute, die die Meldungen schreiben, die wir euch dann vorlesen und das, solange das Leistungsschutzrecht noch nicht ausdiskutiert ist, vielleicht auch noch dürfen. In Zukunft muss ich dann aufpassen, dass ich nicht irgendeinen Satz davon direkt zitiere. Aber wir sind angewiesen auf Leute, die über Netzpolitik schreiben und deswegen ist natürlich ganz klar, dass wir eine Journalistin hier haben müssen heute Abend und deswegen freuen wir uns ganz besonders über Judith Horschert. Judith Horschert ist stellvertretende Ressortleiterin der Spiegel Online Netzwelt.
Judith, komm zu uns. Jetzt erstmal ein Mikrofon aufsetzen, vorher darfst du ja überhaupt nichts sagen. Jetzt geht's los.
Ich hab euch auch ein Geschenk mitgemacht, hier, vielleicht mit den Linus mal auspacken, weil es ist ja so, es gibt nicht immer gute Nachrichten, im Gegenteil, gerade bei euch meistens nicht und manchmal hilft dann eben eher irgendwie Freund Alkohol weiter.
Jetzt geht's aber los.
Das hab ich aus Hamburg mitgebracht und dann sind da zwei Gläser, die hab ich euch extra aus Fort Meat importiert.
Hier, du kriegst die Flasche.
Nee, jeder bekommt ein Glas.
Ich muss dir ein Zimmer auch eins geben.
Ist das okay so mit dem Mikro? Ich kann das nicht.
Man hört dich super. Du kannst jetzt ein bisschen näher noch an den Mund.
Genau, ein bisschen näher ran.
Ich bin das mit dem Headset nicht so gewohnt.
Na ja, kommt noch. Super, das ist ja geil.
Super, ja die haben tatsächlich einen eigenen Giftshop. Die haben so ein kryptologisches Museum.
Das ist so ein richtiges Original.
Das ist ein richtig original aus Ford Meet mitgebracht.
Und der Gin steht da auch? Ach nee, der ist aus Hamburg.
Wo ist die Wanze?
Bestimmt unten. Der Boden ist sehr dick. Ich hab mich auch schon gewundert.
Das ist hier ein bisschen voll alles.
Können wir direkt mal, dürfen wir erzählen, warum du für dich kein Glas mitgebracht hast?
Ja, ich stille noch.
Judith ist nämlich gerade im Mutterschutzurlaub und wird dann bald wieder zur Spiegel online gehen. Deswegen hat sie überhaupt die Zeit.
Urlaub, also dass du das wirklich noch Urlaub nennst.
Mutterschutzurlaub.
Ich bin in Elternzeit.
Elternzeit heißt das.
Den Part hättest du ruhig mich machen lassen können. Jemand, der sich da befasst. Judith, also deinen Namen dürfte die eine oder andere Person und auch die Hörer von Logbuch Netzpolitik schon mal gehört und gelesen haben, denn du hast gerade in den letzten Jahren auch das ganze netzpolitische Geschehen bei Spiegel online mitgeprägt. Du bist da nicht alleine. Ich weiß nicht, wie groß ist euer Team. Fünf Leute. Und hast dich da auf jeden Fall immer ganz ordentlich und lautstark auch geäußert, also auch wie ich finde mit Haltung, also schon mit, ich sage nicht Positionierung, aber Haltung, also das ist sozusagen schon eine gewisse Vehemenz zu spüren, nicht so eine Egalhaltung, ich will mich jetzt hier nicht verplappern.
Unkopf und Kragen reden, ja.
Ja, das ist meine Wahrnehmung und von daher seid ihr halt auch für uns natürlich eine Quelle gewesen und seid es natürlich auch noch. Wie ist denn so deine Wahrnehmung dieser letzten Jahre, insbesondere so seit Snowden, hat das dann bei euch im Online-Journalismus was verändert oder war das Business as usual?
Ja, also erstmal schon mal interessant, dass du sagst als Quelle, weil wir zum Beispiel auch hören, als Quelle, deswegen ist das alles gleichgeschaltet zu kommen, die alle da drauf. Das ist eine versiffte Suppe und so, alles wird genutzt.
Aber das ist ja so eine Feedback-Schleife dann sozusagen.
Ja genau, deswegen drehen wir uns alle nur um uns selbst wahrscheinlich. Die Snowden-Jahre natürlich, also seit 2013, das war wahnsinnig anstrengend. Ich glaube, das war auch für alle, die irgendwie über Netzpolitik berichten, wahnsinnig anstrengend. Und natürlich auch in beiden Teilen, ich habe das mit Sascha Lobo, der ja für uns auch Kolumnist ist, haben wir zwischendurch mal so einen kleinen Breakdown gehabt, wo wir gesagt haben, das ist auch so frustrierend. Also wirklich, es hat die hier gerade schon der erste Gast gesagt, es passiert dann doch sehr wenig. Ich unterstelle das einfach mal, dieses Publikum, was ihr hier so habt, das ist nun sehr engagiert, sehr interessiert und die stehen dann im Zweifel auch mit irgendeinem Transparent vor dem Bundestag. Aber die große Mehrheit eben nicht. Das sind eben dann die Freiheitsstadt Angstgänger, die sind irgendwie immer da und das ist auch wirklich sehr löblich. Ich meine es ganz ernst, es ist wirklich wichtig, sich dazu engagieren. Aber die ganz große Mehrheit und gerade die Masse, für die wir ja nun auch schreiben und berichten, hat dieser Riesenskandal meiner Ansicht nach auf Dauer tatsächlich kaum interessiert. Ich hab nicht das Gefühl, dass die Leute mehr verschlüsseln, ich hab nicht das Gefühl, dass die Leute sich irgendwie mehr überwacht fühlen. Im Gegenteil eigentlich, ja.
Und wie ist das zu erklären? Also ich mein, du wirst das ja nicht nur sehen an dem, was draußen passiert, sondern du bist ja auch als Online-Journalistin in der ersten oder zweiten Generation von Journalisten, die überhaupt damit konfrontiert werden, dass man nachher sieht, was in der Publikation gelesen wird. Das hat doch wahrscheinlich den Journalismus schon auch ein bisschen verändert, oder? Also ich will jetzt nicht sagen, ihr werdet vom Haus kontrolliert und es wird gesagt, ihr müsst jetzt mehr Katzen machen, weil die werden mehr geklickt, aber das wird doch schon eine Rolle spielen, oder?
Naja, es ist nicht so, da möchte ich nochmal gute Nachrichten heute irgendwie hier an den Start bringen. Es ist nicht so, dass die Überwachungsgeschichten und gerade die Snowden-Geschichten sich schlecht geklickt hätten. Das ist wirklich Quatsch. Das haben die Leute schon alles irgendwie gelesen. Wir haben dann zwar immer so Scherze gemacht, der Untersuchungsausschuss und die ganzen Praktikanten, die müssen das jetzt alle lesen und die klicken sich hier durch die Folie und so. Aber es ist nicht so, dass es eine niedrige Klickzahl wäre. Natürlich am Ende gerade Katzen, Katzenkopter, tote Katzen werden zu irgendwelchen Quattkoptern gebaut. Sowas klickt sich natürlich ohne Ende. Und irgendwie wohl auch dann immer irgendwie eine neue Apple-Sache oder so. Das ist halt tatsächlich immer noch so, dass sich das ja geklickt. Aber es wäre auch für unser Haus nie in Frage gekommen, selbst wenn das niemand gelesen hätte, aufzuhören, darüber zu berichten und auch mit dieser Vehemenz zu berichten. Das sind ja auch ganz schön Ressourcen, die da gebunden werden für solche Geschichten. Und das bleibt auch so. Das sage ich direkt schon mal, wenn ich wiederkomme, das bleibt so.
Ja, da kann man schon mal applaudieren.
Ihr habt aber auch so ein nettes Publikum, das will ich auch noch mal sagen, das ist nämlich der Unterschied zwischen so Publikationen wie euch und uns. Bei uns sind da draußen alle und die haten und die haten sofort. Das ist kaum online, da steht da schon irgendwie, das hatte gestern schon Heise und Fefe hat schon alles dazu gesagt, was es dazu noch zu sagen gibt. Und du sitzt da links und denkst, oh mein Gott, ihr habt hier irgendwie einen Stall voller Leute, die halten Schilder hoch und sagen, 200. Folge, das ist doch auch echt sehr schön, solche Fans irgendwie zu haben.
Du bist ja so eine richtige Journalistin, du warst ja auch auf der Henry-Nun-Schule, du hast ja den Journalismus auch so von der Pico auf gelernt, da war ja sozusagen diese Positionierung online nicht unbedingt von Anfang an dabei, oder?
Bei mir nicht, also das wird da alles auch gelehrt. Das ist ja supernett, dass ich auch was Klares zu trinken kriege. Danke schön.
Das haben alle gedacht hier.
Hier werden Getränke reingemacht. Man muss das ja immer nochmal sagen, die Leute, die das hören.
Zum Ende der Sendung bin ich dann auch besoffen.
Danke Henning.
Das wäre dein Applaus gewesen.
Unsere charmante Assistentin Henning.
Also da wird schon alles gelehrt. Natürlich ist es anders, als wenn eine Königsdisziplin Reportage und da wird sehr lange an jedem einzelnen Satz gefeilt. Die Zeit hat man jetzt bei Spiegel Online nicht mehr unbedingt. Dass man sagt, ich muss erstmal ein paar Stunden darüber nachdenken, ob der Übergang da irgendwie so stimmt. Das geht natürlich nicht. Aber wir haben sehr wohl auch Online-Journalismus gelernt. Damals kam noch Stefan Plöchinger von Spiegel Online. Wir hatten schon Agentur Journalismus gemacht, wollte uns mal so ein bisschen eine Idee fürs Tempo und für die Arbeit geben. Und gab uns dann drei Meldungen und eineinhalb Stunden. Und ich dachte so, na ja, da suche ich mir ein Haus und suche ihn. Fand das schon echt eng, irgendwie zeitlich und gibt die halb ab. Ich so hier Stefan und er so, wo sind die anderen beiden? Und ich denke so krass, das kann ich in so einer Zeit leider nicht schreiben. Und da habe ich gesagt, ich gehe niemals im Leben zu Spiegel Online. Hat bestens geklappt. Aber jetzt bin ich da auch sehr glücklich. Und tatsächlich, da gewöhnt man sich dann auch dran an die Taktung und das Tempo.
Wie getrennt ist denn Spiegel und Spiegel Online?
In manchen Sachen sehr getrennt. Also wie gesagt, die einen machen ein Heft und die anderen haben eine Online-Publikation. Das sind zwei Redaktionen, die natürlich dann sehr unterschiedlich arbeiten. Aber tatsächlich, gerade bei den NSE-Geschichten sind sie so ein Klassiker. Wir haben auch gesehen, wir haben sehr viel mit den Kollegen auch hier mit Marcel Rosenbach und Holger Stark und so. Und da sind ja schon die Online-Namen und die Print-Namen zusammen, weil einfach diese ganz großen Geschichten, gerade solche, sich natürlich gar nicht stemmen lassen.
Weil sich das thematisch so anboot? Oder weil das so ein großes Thema ist, dass man an der Stelle die Dinge zusammenführen muss?
Oh, das bin ich jetzt noch schwer gefragt. Also es ist ja so, da arbeiten dann manchmal zwei Redaktionen getrennt an zwei Themen. Das ist natürlich Unsinn und deswegen wird das dann natürlich auch zusammengelegt. Aber in dem speziellen Fall war das auch tatsächlich auch einfach so viel Arbeit, dass tatsächlich jeder, der irgendwie die Ahnung hatte, wie alle zusammengearbeitet haben. Und das hat auch sehr gut geklappt.
Ist das dann vielleicht schon so ein bisschen der erste Fühl für eine Vereinigung dieser beiden Bereiche? Oder siehst du, dass das noch lange getrennt bleiben wird?
Ich bin da wirklich der schlechteste Gesprächspartner, weil ich in der Netzwelt arbeite. Die Netzwelt hat kein korrespondierendes Ressort im Printspiegel. Deswegen kann ich da so ganz schlecht drüber reden, weil da weiß ich nicht, wie das in der Politik und in der Wirtschaft läuft. Aber bei uns in der Netzwelt, wir sind ja ganz allein, wir können da machen, was wir wollen. Wir bloggen eigentlich noch. Das heißt, wenn man jetzt so ein Heft kaufen würde vom Spiegel, da gibt es keine Netzwelt drin.
Da gibt es keine Netzpolitik, ne?
Ja, da gibt es schon Netzpolitik, findet schon statt. Aber es ist dann entweder in der Politik oder in Deutschland oder in Ausland, je nachdem, wo es das anbietet. Aber es gibt keine Netzwelt, wie es die in Spiegel Online gibt.
Neiden die Heftlinge euch, dass ihr das Feedback so schnell kriegt?
Woher hast du das mit den Heftlingen?
Ich habe gedacht, ich sag das einfach mal, ich weiß nicht, ob du das sagen darf. Neiden die euch das schnelle Feedback?
Nee, also erstmal, die schreiben ja auch für online. Es ist ja wirklich keineswegs mehr so wie früher, dass das irgendwie so ganz klar getrennt ist oder so. Sondern natürlich schreiben die auch für online. Ich weiß nicht, ob die sich da wundern. Und diese schnelle Feedback ist ja nicht immer nur neidenswert. Also wie gesagt, da hast du sofort irgendwie, auf Twitter kommt dann sofort irgendwie, ja keine Ahnung, Fehler im dritten Satz, wenn ich schon einen Teaser lese, dann lese ich gar nicht weiter und so. Also es geht ja sehr schnell und wird auch sehr schnell, interessanterweise sehr persönlich. Aber das Krasseste kommt eigentlich gar nicht so durch die sozialen Medien und auch nicht durch unser Forum. Unser Forum ist sehr hart, also da muss man wirklich ganz gut gelaunt sein und in sich ruhen, wenn man sich alle Kommentare zum eigenen Artikel durchlesen möchte. Aber weil das natürlich auch sehr streng moderiert wird, dieses Forum, oder wie viele User...
Zensiert?
Zensiert, natürlich, zensiert wird. Deswegen kommt das Härteste per Mail. Und das, was so keiner sieht, und das kommt halt nur in dein Mailfach oder ins Ressort-Mailfach und da stehen dann so die richtig schlimmen Sachen drin. Und wirklich Beleidigungen und alles. Und da schreibe ich halt manchmal dann schon zurück und sage irgendwie, naja, jetzt, Entschuldigung, so muss ich mich morgens um 8 nicht irgendwie anmachen lassen oder so, oder frage danach. Und da kommen dann interessanterweise auch ganz freundliche und kleinlaute E-Mails zurück. So ein Feedback-Button, ich wusste gar nicht, dass das gelesen wird. Ich meine, ich frage mich, hallo? Aber sie, aber sie melden sich nochmal. Es ist dann wirklich sehr oft so und sagen dann manchmal, komm, mein Tag war scheiße, irgendwie meine Frau hat mich verlassen, ich hack einfach alles rein. Und das kriegen wir bei Spiegel Online ab. Wir nehmen das gern. Habt ihr nette Kommentare, dann wir nehmen den ganzen schon.
Das ist lieb von euch. Was benutzt du eigentlich für einen Adblocker?
Ich trinke mal einen Schluck. Tatsächlich benutze ich wirklich, also jetzt ganz, ganz, wir sind ja hier unter uns. Nein, tatsächlich benutze ich wirklich und habe auch noch nie einen. Also klar, schon mal um zu testen, um zu gucken, wie das aussieht. Aber ich benutze selbstverständlich keinen Adblocker, weil ich lebe von der Werbung. Und ganz viele von meinen Freunden und Bekannten in meiner Filterbabel leben eben auch von der Werbung. Außerdem publiziere ich das, ja. Also tatsächlich möchte ich jetzt auch sehen, wie das aussieht. Also wo die Anzeige ist, wo Fülle geworben wird.
Und wie weit man runterscrollen muss, bis der Artikel kommt.
Genau, bis der Text anfängt. Aber tatsächlich kenne ich natürlich Leute, die Adblocker benutzen. Sollte es geben, wahrscheinlich auch so ein paar da links. Ja, habe ich gehört, habe ich gehört. Und ich kann auch verstehen, also ich kann mir Gründe vorstellen, warum man das tut. Blinkende Werbung und nervige Werbung gehört für mich überhaupt nicht dazu. Aber wenn zum Beispiel jemand sagt, naja, es könnte unter Umständen auch ein Sicherheitsproblem sein, dann ist das auf jeden Fall eine Sache, die wir fixen müssen oder über die wir uns unterhalten müssen. Und tatsächlich, das kann ich aus dem Nähkästchen plaudern, ist das Bewusstsein für dieses, für ein mögliches Sicherheitsproblem, das kommt erst so ganz langsam an in den Verlagen oder in den Werben. Das ist ja auch nicht richtig unser Business. Ich mach das Gegenteil von Werbung, ich mach Journalismus. Aber so ein bisschen merkt man ja, das scheint da irgendwie erst so ganz langsam irgendwie das Verständnis dafür rauszukommen. Aber ich gelobe hiermit, dass wenn ich wieder komme im Frühjahr nach meiner Elternzeit, dass ich das auf jeden Fall auf dem Tisch liegen werde und mich mal ein bisschen kümmern werde. Weil ich sehe ja ein, dass man schlecht sein kann, schallt alle Adblocker aus und sich vorher nicht selber gekümmert hat. Super.
Aber es ist natürlich schon so, wie siehst du denn die Bemühungen oder die Bestrebungen, die jetzt von immer mehr Online-Häusern stattfinden. Ich glaube bei Spiegel Online heißt das, da gibt es jetzt auch diese Plus, bei Süddeutsche Zeitung auch. Das wird jetzt so langsam eingeführt.
Das ist doch was für die Adblock-Nutzer zum Beispiel, weil irgendwie in irgendeiner Form bezahlt werden muss. So sieht das nochmal aus. Tatsächlich könnte man ja dann sagen, wir haben immer ganz viele Mails bekommen, ich lasse meinen Adblock an, ich würde ja was bezahlen und so, da haben wir jetzt alle Gelegenheit zu.
Und?
Ich weiß tatsächlich, weil ich bin nicht im Moment da für Arbeit, das müsste ich mal reichen, ich habe aber gerne meinen neuen Kommentaren nach.
Also ich sehe das schon, das ist schon ein spannender Konflikt, in dem der Journalismus da jetzt steckt. Du möchtest natürlich einerseits deine Reichweite entfalten, deine Reichweite nutzen, du machst das, wie gesagt, du bist Journalist und nicht irgendwie Werbeheftverteiler. Vom Selbstempfinden her. Was soll das denn heißen? Nein, nein, nein. Nein, das war ein blöder Kommentar, den meine ich nicht so, wie ich ihn gesagt habe. Aber man hat diesen journalistischen Anspruch, aber man ist natürlich auch in dieser Welt daraus, die wahrscheinlich echt eine andere ist, als ich mir so vorstelle, man sich das vorgestellt hat, wenn man als in der Henry-Nannen-Schule vor ein paar Jahren war, als das zwar langsam absehbar war, dass sich der Journalismus ändern würde, aber dass er sich so grundlegend ändern würde. Und ich glaube, dass also vielleicht war es auch nie anders, als dass man die großen, fetten Reportagen geschrieben hat, damit man die Preise gewinnt und den was weiß ich, S-Klasse, Farbericht, damit das Blatt sich verkauft. dass der Journalismus schon in so einer Krise ist, das würde ich sagen, vielleicht bei Spiegel online jetzt nicht.
Der ist ja immer ständig in der Krise, ja, ja, also er ist ja andauernd in der Krise, aber nicht unbedingt deswegen. Weil es ist auch nicht so, dass ich keine Reportagen schreiben könnte, weil ich bei Spon bin und muss da von morgens bis abends tickern und nur Meldungen schreiben. Also als ich hier gerade als Meldungsschreiberin vorgestellt worden bin, das hat mir schon ein bisschen wehgetan. du kannst auch Kommentare schreiben, du kannst Reportagen schreiben und dann ist auch schon so, gerade diese großen Sachen, glaubt man nicht, dass so ein NSA-End-Katalog irgendwie in der Mittagspause entsteht, da sitzt ja auch Wochen dran. Das ist schon sehr viel Arbeit und auch sehr viel Freiraum, den man sich da nehmen kann für eine große Geschichte. Das muss man schon sagen. Man muss nicht den ganzen Tag Meldung schreiben und sagen, blöd, jetzt konnte ich schon wieder keine Reportage haben.
Aber du musst es am Ende irgendwie kostenlos raushauen. So wie wir bei Logbuch Netzpolitik. Auch nur, dass wir nicht darauf angewiesen sind, dass am Ende...
Es ist werbefinanziert, was heißt kostenlos? Ich werde ja bezahlt dafür, dass ich etwas online stelle und das lesen sehr viele Leute. Und da ist natürlich recht, dass eine jegliche Paywall, wie auch immer die geartet ist, natürlich Leser wegnimmt. Dann natürlich weniger Leser, das kann man schonmal auf jeden Fall sagen.
Und irgendwie trauen sich die Verlagshäuser offenbar jetzt erst gemeinschaftlich, das jeder einzeln zu machen. Also ich habe eigentlich damit gerechnet, dass sie innerhalb von zehn Jahren, die das Thema jetzt schon lange entscheidend eine Rolle spielt, ich glaube, Spiegelohne ist sogar 20 Jahre alt, also seit zehn Jahren kann man echt sagen, das Thema ist einfach wirklich bedrohlich für viele Verlagshäuser oder relevant für die Verlagshäuser. Ich hätte ja gedacht, dass sie es in zehn Jahren irgendwann mal hinkriegen, sich zusammen zu rotten und ein gemeinsames Bezahlding zu machen.
Ist das nicht schön, dass sich nicht alle zusammengerottet haben? Also jetzt eine ganz einzelne Judetor, ich habe Meinung, aber ist doch schön. Ich möchte nicht dann die, was alle schon fürchten, gleichgeschaltete Presse, wo alle unter einer Decke stecken und alle voneinander nicht mal abschreiben, sondern dann auch noch gemeinsam verdienen. Ich bin sehr froh, dass das nicht der Fall ist. Und ich werde das auch jedem Pegida und wer auch immer mir irgendwie gegenüber steht, immer wieder sagen, auch wenn die immer sagen, ja ja, du lügst doch, lügst doch, Lügenpresse. Ich werde immer sagen, nein, es ist aber eben nicht so. Und ich bin sehr froh, dass es nicht so ist.
Die Werbung lügt aber.
Höchstwahrscheinlich. Auch nicht alle. Meister Proppe macht das sauber, oder? Ich dachte, ich weiß nicht, ich hab das alles gelogen.
Bleiben wir noch mal kurz bei dieser Glaubwürdigkeitsfrage. Weil ich hab jetzt auch, wenn ich mir das ganze USA-Geschehen so ein bisschen parallel antue, das kann man ja wirklich nur so mit 5% wahrnehmen, sonst geht man ja irgendwie komplett kaputt. So ein bisschen so dieses... Ich fang mal anders an. So in meiner Jugend und mittleren Aufzucht, da war sozusagen die Zeitung das Normative. Und natürlich auch das Fernsehen ein Stück weit. Vielleicht irgendwann sogar noch ein bisschen mehr als die Zeitung. Aber das hatte sozusagen immer so eine intellektuelle Lufthoheit. Letztlich war das, was da quasi so der wahrnehmbare Konsens war, das war dann irgendwo auch der staatliche Diskurs. Und ich hab so ein bisschen das Gefühl, dass jetzt eben durch diese Disruption des Netzes, aber eben auch durch diese Disruption der Dummheit, die wir ja mit Reike auch schon angesprochen hatten, da irgendwie so ein bisschen der Boden wegsickert. Ich kriege manchmal das Gefühl, es ist vollkommen egal, also selbst wenn die FAZ und die TATS morgen irgendwie dieselbe Meinung, was sie ja in gewisser Hinsicht, wenn man sich so Trump und so weiter anschaut, da sind die ja irgendwie alle nicht mehr so weit auseinander, dass das dann trotzdem irgendwie auch gar nicht mehr verfängt. Also dass diese Lufthalruheit irgendwie weg ist. Dass da irgendwie so ein Cyberwalk quasi am Star ist, der sozusagen von Flugzeugen ist. Das ist mir doch egal, was ihr da durch die Gegend fliegt. Das zählt hier nicht mehr. Siehst du das genauso bedrohlich wie ich?
Naja, ich glaube, dass die Leute, es gibt eine gewisse Gruppe, habe ich das Gefühl, die erreichen wir nicht mehr. Wenn eine Gruppe glaubt, dass die Presse, egal welche, grundsätzlich lügt, dann wird es sehr schwer. Ist völlig egal, ob es die Faz ist oder die Taz oder wer auch immer, ist es egal. Wenn man das einfach glaubt, dass in jeder Zeitung Lügen stehen, dann haben wir ein Problem. Dieses Problem haben wir jetzt und dann müssen wir uns auseinandersetzen, wie und ob man diese Menschen jemals noch erreicht. Was allerdings jeder kann schreiben, was er möchte im Netz, das wollen wir doch gerade, das ist doch gerade schön. Ich finde zum Beispiel, wir freuen uns doch alle über die Blogs, dass die Experten irgendwie alle, jeder kann einen Blog machen, einen Podcast machen und vor sich hin seiern und erzählen. Das freut mich sehr. Da darf man nichts sagen, finde ich. Aber die Chem-Trades-Leute dürfen das nicht. Doch, natürlich ist es ja das Schöne im Netz, dass es dann diese Vielfalt gibt und alle dann in ihrem Expertentum. Und wenn die dann eben finden, dass das Reptiloide sind, Hillary Clinton und so, dann sollen sie das publizieren können. Dafür ist das Netz ja da, dass jeder überall publizieren kann.
Nicht bei uns allerdings.
Also bist du auch ein Reptiloide?
Ja, wer weiß das schon.
Ich empfehle ihr ja immer gerne Twitter-Accounts. Ich weiß nicht genau, wie er heißt, aber Chemtrades24 ist immer super, was da irgendwie alles im Shop ist. Kann man sich gerade das passende Wetter zusammen kaufen.
Ist das Problem denn also außer in der Kommentarspalte, wo sich ja alle Probleme der Gesellschaft manifestieren, ist das Problem denn wirklich jetzt an anderer Stelle spürbar? Also das würde mich jetzt echt mal interessieren. Man sieht das bei Sponnen jetzt langsam, ich weiß nicht, ob das schon immer so was wird, natürlich auch mehr thematisiert, dann siehst du mal einen Artikel, da gibt es keine Kommentarmöglichkeit, dann siehst du mal einen Artikel, wo von vornherein drin steht so, bitte, wenn ihr versucht, hier zu kommentieren, versucht mal so grob irgendwie über der Tischkante zu bleiben mit dem Unterkiefer oder so. Und ist es wirklich schlimmer geworden? Also müssen wir jetzt Mark Zuckerberg verhaften? Oder war es vielleicht auch schon immer scheiße? Und es wird jetzt nur zum ersten Mal thematisiert. Das würde mich schon tatsächlich interessieren. Vor ein paar Jahren war das da so, war das irgendwie Blümchenwiese?
Nee, nee, nee, war es glaube ich nie. Also es war schon immer schlimm und es wird immer schlimmer. Das hat ja jeder irgendwie so ein bisschen in sich, das zu glauben. Und jetzt nimmt das aber wirklich neue Formen an. Das weiß ich gar nicht, aber tatsächlich dadurch, dass es auch bezahlte Kommentarschreiber gibt, und das merkt man auch, also da müsste jemand aus dem Forum von uns einladen, die kennen sich da natürlich bestens aus, dass es bezahlte, also ganze Horten von Kommentarschreibern, die so gleichzeitig Sachen abschicken gibt oder so, hat das vielleicht eine neue Dimension bekommen. Und manchmal denke ich auch, also was Rassismus angeht, das habe ich selber so das Gefühl, in einem derartigen Maße, dass man jetzt schon sagen und schreiben kann, offenbar, wie gesagt, also was man will und das auch tut in diesem Maße, das habe ich irgendwie, das habe ich früher nicht so empfunden. Ich habe das Gefühl, dass Rassismus tatsächlich irgendwie, für irgendeine Gruppe von Menschen salonfähig geworden ist und auch in jedem Forum Platz findet, und das finde ich tatsächlich sehr, sehr besorgniserregend.
Ich habe mir so ein bisschen Gedanken darüber gemacht, was da eigentlich gerade passiert, mit diesem Internet und diesem Medienwandel und so, warum wir auch so ein bisschen hilflos vor diesem Phänomen stehen. Es würde mich auch mal interessieren, ob du das irgendwie, wie du das so wahrnimmst. Ich habe so ein bisschen den Eindruck, dass dieser hetzerische Unterton, diese rassistischen Tendenzen, dieses ganze Abkotzen über, wie die Dinge so sind und warum sie nicht so sind, wie sie früher mal waren, war ja immer da. Wir sehen ja nicht irgendwie etwas, was es jetzt die letzten 50 Jahre nicht gegeben hat. Jetzt hat es irgendeiner ausgebuddelt und alle so, oh, das ist ja mal eine interessante Sichtweite. Sondern es war halt irgendwie da. Aber es war halt versteckt im Stammtisch. Es war in seinen engen Räumen verbreitet unter Leuten, die eben sozusagen auch gar keine Netzwerke hatten, die jetzt irgendwie weiter griffen als über so das eigene Dorf oder eine gewisse Region hinaus. Einige mehr, aber die allermeisten weniger. Durch Facebook und nicht nur Facebook, aber Medien wie Facebook ist es jetzt sozusagen für jedermann möglich, diesen Stammtisch quasi zu verbreitern. Auf einmal funken alle Stammtische in sich hinein. Das findet gleichzeitig statt mit so einer Ignoranz des Wandels aus der intellektuellen Szene. Immer dieses, ach ja, dieses Internet und so, das geht ja schon wieder weg und so. Ich habe so ein bisschen den Eindruck, dass dadurch, dass quasi so die Elite, Airquotes, sich diesem Wandel nicht so hingegeben hat, sie die Zeit verspielt hat, hier auch entsprechende Strategien zu entwickeln bzw. überhaupt alles mal mit diesem Medium auch umgehen zu können. Und jetzt hat sich irgendwie so dieser hetzerische Pöbel so einfach so, ah, das wäre super, das machen wir jetzt mal, quasi so hintenrum range schlichen und jetzt haben wir irgendwie diesen Zustand. Ist in gewisser Hinsicht auch ein optimistischer Blick?
Nee, du bist ganz pessimistisch. Das ist wieder so Logbuch Netzpolitik, so ist alles zu spät. Die Elite hat irgendwie nicht aufgepasst und jetzt sitzen wir hier.
Ich sag dir, warum ich das als optimistischen Blick sehe, weil ich das quasi nur als Momentaufnahme sehe. Und ich denke, dass wir sozusagen aus dem intellektuellen Milieu heraus jetzt eben auch quasi nachholen müssen und den Kampf wieder eher kurz aufnehmen müssen.
Ja, geh hin, geh zu den Stammtischen, das ist eigentlich ganz gut. Die sind auch jetzt zu erreichen. Vorher in so eine dunkle Kneipe, da hättest du dich einfach mal reintrauen müssen. Da wärst du wahrscheinlich nie wieder rausgekommen. Jetzt kannst du doch auf Facebook mischen, da steh ich doch ein. Man ist müde, ich auch. Ich trau mich das auch manchmal auch da nicht. Und denk da so, oh nein, wenn ich mich mit denen jetzt anlege, da block ich doch lieber. Aber dann hab ich mir auch gedacht, nee, man sollte vielleicht gar nicht unbedingt blocken, sondern vielleicht erreichen wir sie ja doch noch irgendwie irgendwo da.
Ja oder wir machen VHS-Kopien von Raiq Anders und schicken das dahin.
Wir treffen uns dann.
Judith, super, dass du bei uns warst. Vielen, vielen Dank.
Vielen Dank für die Einladung.
Alles Gute.
Vielen Dank für das Geschenk.
So, ich nutze jetzt noch mal rund zur Stunde, wo das hier so ein bisschen unruhiger wird. Ganz viele, ach ihr kriegt so viele Mitlikes für den Stream, der hier läuft. Ein Herzchen und das läuft richtig ab. Frauenquote stimmt.
Ja sicher.
Ihr berichtet auf dem Twitter irgendwie.
Die haben noch nicht in den Sender und schleichlich viel Cocktail.
Ich hab mir eine Schelte eingefahren, weil ich euch Getränke gebracht hab und ihr die Cocktails von den inkorrekten irgendwie verschmäht habt.
Die kommen dann später nicht.
Also ich hab die Cocktails verschmäht, da hab ich mir eine Schelte eingefahren.
Wie gesagt, die müsst ihr gleich noch trinken, ja. Und vor allen Dingen gehen die Leute auf dem Twitter richtig ab über das, was da oben läuft. Ja, das gucken wir uns dann danach an. Ich glaube, ihr solltet irgendwie mal kurz erklären, wer das macht, warum man das macht und ob es die Dinge nachher zum Download gibt. Also da sind wirklich die Leute, die wollen das da oben haben. Und jetzt macht ihr weiter.
Regie, könnt ihr mir mal seine Funke auch noch mit auf den Kopfhörer geben, das ist hier nicht auf dem Mix. Das war nicht für dich, das war für die Regie.
Für die Regie, für die Regie.
Ja, also die Zeichnungen da oben sind von Roland Brückner. Ein sehr guter Freund von mir. Und ich weiß nicht, wie er damit verfahren wird, wenn die fertig sind. Aber ich glaube, der wird sie bestimmt irgendwo bereitstellen. Das könnte ich mir sehr gut vorstellen. Wir werden auch noch andere Späße damit machen.
So, von den Journalisten zu den Aktivisten. Ja, die brauchen wir auch noch. Ja, hatten wir auch schon ein bisschen.
Irgendwie Sinn machen aus dieser Sinnung. Und wenn man sich jetzt mal so über Aktivismus unterhält, dann ist Aktivismus ja auch im Handel über die Zeit, die man ihn betreibt. Und da sind uns zwei Personen insbesondere eingefallen, die den Aktivismus immer unterschiedlich, auch vielleicht in einem kurzen Zeitraum betrieben haben und irgendwie ein Gespür dafür zu haben scheinen, ihn auch dort zu betreiben, wo er dann irgendwie doch verfängt und funktioniert. Und immer wieder anders. Und darüber möchten wir sprechen mit Anke Domscheit-Berg und Daniel Domscheit-Berg.
So, verteilt euch hier links, rechts, wie ihr möchtet. Hallo Anke, Daniel, kommst du auf meine Seite?
Ihr müsst jetzt so Headsets haben. Genau. Vorher hört man euch nicht.
Macht das Mikrofon schon nah ran, sonst bläst euch hier der Linus akustisch weg. Wir reden gerne laut.
Noch mal noch etwas näher.
Hört man das? Boah, krass, hier blendet ja sogar alles.
Ja, man hört super, aber man sieht nichts.
Man sieht nichts, ist egal, wir wollen ja jetzt auch uns…
Das Podcast, man sieht nichts.
Genau.
Ja, für uns Radiogesichter ist das alles gut. Genau das Richtige. Ja, also ganz kurz, wir haben euch ja auch was mitgebracht, nur dass das abgehakt ist. In der irrigen Annahme, dass ihr morgens podcastet, ja. Transparenz wurde jetzt geschaffen, also eigentlich können wir das wieder mitnehmen, aber da jeder gerne Kaffee trinkt, das weiß ich auch von diversen Camps und der Kaffeemaschine bei uns, also Hannesmaschine, die bei uns steht. Dann lecker Kaffee, da steht drauf, dass der richtig lecker ist, also ich geh jetzt mal davon aus, was schwarz verpackt ist, kann auch nicht schlecht sein, also von daher ist das...
Aus Äthiopien und Kolumbien, super.
Vielen Dank, den werden wir morgen direkt brauchen. Müssen wir Anke und Daniel überhaupt noch vorstellen?
Sollten wir machen.
Fangen wir mit Anke an. Genau. Wie stellt man nicht vor? Anke ist die einzige Person, die heute auf der Bühne ist, die schon mal in einem Podcast von Logbuch Netzpolitik ganz kurz war. Damals habe ich dir die Frage bei einer Veranstaltung gestellt. Anke, was muss jetzt geschehen? Das war in dem... Ich weiß nicht mehr, wie die Veranstaltung heißt, ich weiß nicht mehr, wie dieses Theater heißt, am Rosa-Luxemburg-Platz. Volkstheater. Volksbühne heißt es. Richtig, schön. Da war so eine Veranstaltung, da hat Bruce Stirling gesprochen und ich glaube, da haben wir uns auch kurz unterhalten. Da habe ich dich gefragt, was muss jetzt geschehen, aber das wollte ich nur als Einleitung sagen, wie stellt man dich überhaupt noch vor? Also man kann diese Microsoft-Vergangenheit erwähnen, man kann irgendwie Piraten erwähnen, man kann so viel erwähnen, was man nicht erwähnen sollte. Anke hat gesagt, ich soll es nicht machen, deswegen stell dich doch mal selber vor.
Fällt mir auch nicht so einfach, so leicht.
Wie verstehst du dich selbst?
Also ich glaube, die einfachste Beschreibung ist, ich bin so eine Art Multipler Persönlichkeit, weil ich mache viele verschiedene Dinge sehr gern. Und mal die einen mehr und mal die anderen und die Bandbreite ist ziemlich hoch. Also wenn man das biografisch beschreiben müsste oder grafisch-biografisch, dann wäre das einfach nur ein Zickzack. So nach dem Motto, die Frau macht tausend verschiedene Dinge, aber ich mach das halt gerne. Für mich ist das nicht, also keine Veränderung meiner Persönlichkeit, sondern das ist meine Persönlichkeit. Und dazu gehört, dass ich zum Beispiel in der DDR angewandte Kunst studiert hab. Ich habe aber durch verschiedene biografische Unfälle, bin ich dann bei Unternehmen wie Microsoft oder McKinsey und Accenture gelandet und hab IT-Projekte geleitet. Und 2011 hatte ich halt die Schnauze voll von Corporates und hab mich der Freiheit verschrieben und dem Weltverbessern, ja Weltverbesserin trifft es auch ein bisschen gut. Da haben wir uns gesucht und gefunden, weil zusammen geht es leichter und man kann das halt. Man kann das auf ganz unterschiedliche Dinge tun. Also es gibt so zwei, drei Themen, die mir besonders wichtig sind. Eins ist das Thema Geschlechtergerechtigkeit. Das fiel mir auf, als ich als Ossi im Westen gearbeitet hab und ein Kind bekam und man das da irgendwie komisch und seltsam fand mit Kind zu arbeiten, als hätte man ein Gehirn geboren und kein Kind. Das fand ich gewöhnungsbedürftig und deswegen habe ich beschlossen, da muss man was dagegen tun. Und andere Themen, die mich sehr befassen, ist was die digitale Gesellschaft für Potenziale hat, wie man es dazu kriegt, dass es die guten Potenziale werden und nicht die schlechten für uns alle. Und insbesondere Themen, die auch mit Politik zu tun haben, also wie so Open Government, wie macht man Politik transparent, partizipativ, wie können Menschen sich mehr beteiligen. Da sind wir noch weit weg von dem, was man als gut bezeichnen könnte und wo es sich lohnt, aber weiter dafür zu kämpfen. Weil so viele Leute heute frustriert sind und aufgrund dessen wahrscheinlich sehr seltsame Entscheidungen treffen, hat unter anderem auch mit diesem extremen Misstrauen zu tun. Deswegen versuche ich sozusagen über Top-Down Transparenz zu schaffen, indem ich versuche, Politik zu beeinflussen, dass sie halt von selber transparenter wird und Open Data macht und alles solche Sachen. Da wo ich das nicht schaffe, da ist dann sozusagen das Feld, wo Daniels Aktivitäten anfangen.
Ja, Daniel, für diejenigen, die es nicht wissen, hat früher mal einen sehr radikalen Ansatz verfolgt in der offenen transparenten Politik bei WikiLeaks. Ist aber inzwischen in ganz anderen Bereichen unterwegs. Ich hab eigentlich mich gefragt, warum ihr noch gar nicht die Geflüchtetenhilfe erwähnt habt, die euch ja auch ein Thema ist, was euch sehr am Herzen liegt, wie ich weiß.
Ja, ich glaube, was vielleicht gerade noch fehlt in der Schilderung von Anke ist, und ich glaube, das ist das, was Aktivisten im weitesten Sinne ja ausmacht, ist, dass man da aktiv wird, wo man Handlungsbedarf sieht. Und ich bin nicht gerne passiv, ich sitze nicht gerne rum und beklag mich über die Welt. Das wurde ja heute Abend auch schon so das ein oder andere mal thematisiert. Ich glaube, es ist ganz wichtig, dass wir da, wo wir Missstände feststellen, dass wir nicht verzweifeln oder irgendwie die Lust verlieren oder den Mut verlieren, sondern dass wir als junge Generation, so würde ich mich auch immer noch bezeichnen, aber als die Generation, die heute voll im Leben steht, dass wir verstehen, dass wir alles verändern können, was wir verändern möchten. Und alles, was es dafür braucht, ist, dass wir alle was dafür tun, jede einzelne. Und ich glaube, das ist ein Ding, was mit der Digitalisierung kommt, weil Digitalisierung und das, was das Internet ermöglicht, jedem, jedes Individuum, jedem Einzelnen mehr Macht gibt, als das jemals vorher in der Geschichte der Menschheit der Fall war. Wir können uns so gut vernetzen, wir können uns organisieren, wir können so viel lernen, so viel erfahren, so viel verstehen. Und das ist die Grundlage für alles, was Veränderung bringen kann. Und von daher glaube ich, dass das die Verantwortung, die wir haben. Und ich versuche immer, wenn ich irgendwas sehe, wo sich, wo Handlungsbedarf besteht, mich da zu involvieren. Und dieses ganze Thema rund um mehr Transparenz und Whistleblower und so was, das war eben 2007, als das bei Wikileaks für mich losging, so ein Thema, wo ich dachte, das kommt, das ist kein Zufall, das ist ein Thema, was in dieser Zeit, in dieser Veränderung, die die Gesellschaft gerade durchmacht, ganz wichtig ist. Und im Moment ist das zum Beispiel unter anderem auch das Thema Geflüchtete. Ich war da ganz pragmatisch irgendwann mal, habe ich im Fernsehen im letzten Jahr so ein Plakat gesehen, da stand drauf, irgendwie der Flüchtlingswahn ist heilbar, holt euch die Geflüchteten nach Hause oder so. Und dann dachte ich, wir probieren das einfach mal. Und im Endeffekt ist genau das Gegenteil passiert. Nee, also die Idee, dass man dann keine Lust mehr hat zu helfen oder so, das war ja das, was da propagiert werden sollte. Ja, also ich glaube, es ist halt ganz wichtig, dass man sich mit dem, was passiert in der Welt, irgendwie auseinandersetzt. Und von daher ist das auch wie ähnlich wie bei Anke, wenn Themen vorbeikommen und das ist irgendwie interessant oder braucht gerade irgendwen, der sich kümmert, dann wird das halt einfach gemacht.
Ich würde gerne, dass mich mal kurz, du hast vielleicht eben mitbekommen, wie ich so meine Thesen mit Judith, irgendwie so dieser digitale Stammtische und so weiter. Ich habe jetzt aus seiner Grundaussage eben so, auch so ein Digital-Obsimismus rausgehört. Ich hatte auch vor x Jahren, war ich mal im Chaos-Radio, da haben wir so Twitter-Demokratie und so voll so, ja, jetzt können sich alle beteiligen und jetzt werden die Missstände sichtbar und dann vernetzen wir uns alle und dann wird irgendwie alles gut. Sieht ja gerade nicht so aus, oder?
Ja, aber, hm, also ich weiß nicht. Der einzige Unterschied ist doch heute, dass es viel mehr Menschen gibt, die dieses Werkzeug Internet benutzen. Und wenn ich jetzt überlege, ich bin Mitte der 90er ins Internet gekommen, so wenn ich an die ersten Monate oder Jahre auf irgendwelchen Mailinglisten zurückdenke, so da war der Umgangston jetzt auch nicht wirklich so fortgeschritten und besonders höflich. So damals war das halt The Flame War und heute ist das irgendwie der Shitstorm. Das ist das einzige, was sich verändert hat, ist die die Quantität der Menschen, die teilnehmen und der Umstand, dass viel mehr Menschen heute im Internet eben noch in dieser sehr frühen Phase ihrer Teilhabe sind und wenn du auf einmal alles sagen kannst und mal endlich alles rauslassen kannst und das war bei mir in den 90ern irgendwann auch mal so, dass ich irgendwie gedacht habe, endlich kann ich mal irgendetwas hier sagen, was ich schon immer mal loswerden wollte. Aber wenn das heute halt so viele sind, dann ist das glaube ich einfach ein Phänomen der Zeit und das Umstand ist, dass so viele Leute so neu sind. Und das ist das ganze Thema rund um Medienkompetenz, um Bildung, um Empathie im Internet. So auf der anderen Seite mal irgendwann am Receiving End von irgendwie einem Shitstorm zu sitzen und zu verstehen, wie scheiße sich das anfühlt. Und ich glaube, dass das deswegen ein bisschen was ist, was wir aussitzen müssen und was wir nur lösen können, wenn wir sicherstellen, dass Leute Zugang bekommen zu einer Perspektive da und zu Bildung im weitesten Sinne oder wie auch immer man das nennen möchte, das klingt jetzt zu groß.
Aber trotzdem ist es ja auch so ein Element, du hast ja auch eine Zeit lang mit den Piraten probiert, das war ein holpriger, steiniger Weg, sag ich mal. Da hat man ja auch so ein bisschen den Eindruck gehabt, dass diese Online-Diskussionskultur so einen Großteil dazu beigetragen hat, dass alles so ein bisschen sich genauso holprig entwickelt hat.
Das ist natürlich kein Phänomen, dass man nur da trifft, aber war da tatsächlich teilweise schwer zu ertragen. Ich glaube aber nicht, dass das generelle Problem durch Aussitzen weggeht. Ich glaube, dass wir da als Gesellschaft schon eine wirklich große Aufgabe haben und dass wir da an sozialem Miteinander noch ganz viel lernen müssen, weil was Kinder ja relativ früh beigebracht kriegen, ist, wenn sie Mobbing im Schulhof irgendwo sehen, dass dann nicht nur der Mobber irgendwie Täter ist, sondern alle, die zugucken, auch dazu beitragen, dass Mobbing sich fortsetzt. Und das finde ich ist noch viel zu häufig, wenn wir solchen Hass und Sexismus und Homophobie und Rassismus und wirklich unerträgliche Kommunikationskulturen im Internet erleben, dass zu viele Leute da noch zu still sind, weil sie möglicherweise Schiss haben, dass sie das nächste Target sind, was ja nicht unberechtigt ist. Aber trotzdem ist es ja am Ende eine Frage der Verhältnisse. Und ich glaube nicht, dass die Mehrheit so kommuniziert. Ich glaube nur, dass die Mehrheit halt dazu guckt und nichts sagt. Und das ist ein Phänomen, das müssen wir verändern, sonst kriegen wir das nicht weg, weil es sich ja hochschaukelt durch die Filterblasen und alles Mögliche. Und ich sehe da schon auch eine gefährliche Sache, weil ich das als Feministin natürlich auch noch mal mit einer anderen Perspektive sehe und man da auf eine ganz andere Art und Weise angegriffen wird, die wirklich einfach wehtut. Wenn man da also geschrieben kriegt auf Twitter und jeder kann es lesen, dass man eine minderbemittelte, unterfegte Heslette ist, dann kann man sich sagen, okay schlechter Humor, aber irgendwie wenn man sowas halt öfter mal kriegt und immer wieder und eigentlich völlig egal was für politische Aussagen man gerade getroffen hat, dann ist das nicht in Ordnung. Und ich weiß, also ich mache ja trotzdem weiter. Ich weiß aber Personen, die sich sagen, ich mache das nicht mehr oder ich traue mich nicht in eine politische Öffentlichkeit, weil ich dann zu viel von diesem Hass abkriege. Ich habe Angst davor, ja.
Du hast gerade das mit dem Schulhof verglichen, wo Kinder was beigebracht bekommen, dass sie irgendwie miteinander vernünftig umgehen müssen. Ich bin mir nicht so sicher, ob das die Kinder auf dem Schulhof wirklich dann irgendwann auch mal gelernt haben. Das ist eher rausgewachsen, war so ein bisschen mein Eindruck.
Ja, das ist ja die Aussetztheorie. Also ich glaube nicht, dass wir das aussetzen können.
Die Frage, wer würden die, glaubst du, man kann es dem Netz beibringen? Also glaubst du, das ist vielleicht echt so eine Phase? Also wir sind jetzt alle gerade so Internet-Menschen, sind alle noch so ein bisschen im Grundschulniveau. Wir probieren jetzt mal alles aus, probieren Grenzen aus und irgendwann wird sich ein gesellschaftlicher Konsens darüber etablieren, wie man miteinander umgeht.
Ich hoffe, dass das so ist und also in einem sehe ich das schon auch so, dass das Zeit braucht, aber es passiert halt nicht von selber, sondern es braucht einen bewussten Diskurs.
Ja, das auf jeden Fall. Also das wollte ich jetzt auch gar nicht sagen, dass wir da einfach nur warten müssen, aber ich glaube, dass es zum Erwachsenwerden gehören ja auch Erfahrungen zu machen und das glaube ich, die spielen da mit rein. Es braucht aber halt trotzdem auch diese Zeit. Und ein bisschen, da würde ich Anke total zustimmen, viel mehr Menschen, die sich auch einfach klar positionieren. Und auch das ist ja, da sind wir jetzt wieder bei dem, was ich einleitend versucht habe zu sagen, so wir leben in einer Zeit, in der wir uns überhaupt nicht leisten können, dass so viele Leute einfach wegschauen. Ob das der Hass im Internet ist oder ob das Themen sind wie ACTA oder TTIP oder was auch immer oder jetzt das neue Überwachungsgesetz, was irgendwie durchgewunken wurde. Das sind alles Themen, wir können uns überhaupt nicht leisten, einfach wegzuschauen als Gesellschaft und uns zu denken, dass sich das von alleine lösen wird. Ich glaube, dass wir total unterschätzen, um das noch mal zu sagen, wie viel Macht wir haben. Das ist gerade diese Community hier, die Leute, die das Internet verstehen, die die Tools des Internets bedienen können. Wenn ich so überlege, die ganze Masse an Menschen, die mittlerweile zum Beispiel zum Kongress kommt, im Dezember, das sind über 10.000 Leute, wenn die sich zusammentun würden, die könnten alles verändern, was sie verändern wollen. Und es gäbe überhaupt niemanden, der das stoppen könnte, davon bin ich vollkommen überzeugt. Und das ist eine Verantwortung, die überhaupt noch nicht auf dem Schirm ist, glaube ich. Und auch eine Möglichkeit, die so nicht auf dem Schirm ist.
Und die sollten wir erreichen.
Ja, ich glaube schon.
Habt ihr gehört?
Das... Und das fängt ja an bei so ganz wichtigen Sachen wie Jugendhackt und Chaos macht Schule und all diesen Dingen, dass man jungen Leuten zum Beispiel zeigt, dass sie das schaffen können, was sie sich vorstellen, dass sie die Möglichkeit haben, Ideen umzusetzen und dass das alles so niedrigschwellig geworden ist heute. Ich glaube, wir, gerade wir, die in dieser Community irgendwie so verhaftet sind, wir sehen auch den Wald vor lauter Bäumen so oft nicht, weil das alles so normal geworden ist und wir unterschätzen total, wie radikal diese ganze Veränderung ist, die für uns irgendwie so alltäglich geworden ist.
Aber es sind schon auch analoge Themen, wo ich würde noch mal gerne auf das Thema Flüchtlinge zurückkommen. Also da kann man sowohl digital als auch analog eine Menge machen. Da gibt es diese Coda-Projekte für Geflüchtete. Bei dem Refugee Hackathon, den ich letztes Jahr initiiert hatte, da sind ganz viele Leute gekommen und haben Apps entwickelt, wo man einerseits Geflüchteten das Leben erleichtert hat, aber auch denen, die ihnen helfen wollten. Genauso kann man aber auch gucken, ob man vielleicht ein WG-Zimmer für die frei hat oder Sprache beibringen oder was wir also wirklich bis zum Umfallen machen und echt nicht mehr sehen können, weil die Formulare so scheiße sind, ist, dass man einfach Formulare ausfüllt. Es gibt für alles Formulare und wir kommen ja schon kaum mit den Dingern klar, wie soll das jemand, der die deutsche Sprache nicht versteht, wie soll der Rentenversicherungsformulare, Kindergartenanträge, Schulanträge, Hortgedöns und was weiß ich, Jobcenter, das nimmt ja alles gar kein Ende und selbst wenn man nicht regelmäßig und jeden Tag dafür Zeit hat, jeder der sich intensiver um Geflüchtete kümmert, freut sich, wenn ihm ein Einnahme ein Formular abnimmt und da auch mal so an ganz einfache, analoge Dinge zu denken und da selber einen Unterschied zu machen, macht zusammen genommen auch einen riesengroßen Unterschied. Das machen ja schon total viele. Wir hören immer nur von AfD und alle, die irgendwie Mist erzählen und rassistische Dinge ablassen, aber dass über eine Million Menschen, ich glaube, es sind sogar noch mehr, in der Freiwilligenhilfe aktiv sind, das wird viel zu selten gesagt, weil gute Nachrichten sind irgendwie uninteressant. Ich verstehe gar nicht, warum.
Die sind eigentlich viel interessanter.
Kommen wir doch mal zu eurem jüngsten Projekt.
Das finde ich insofern, wenn ich kurz dazwischen greifen kann. Ihr zeigt private Initiative, ihr habt es irgendwie auf dem politischen Weg probiert, teilweise noch, und jetzt auch noch irgendwie auf so einem unternehmerischen Pfad. Das ist ganz interessant, Fin. So Leute, jetzt ratet mal. Geht nämlich um den größten Schmerz in uns.
Ja, das sehen wir ja auch so. Also das ganze Thema rund um Breitband aus.
Genau, wir wollen nämlich alle Internet haben, oder?
Symmetrisches Internet, fangen wir mal so an.
Schnelles, schnelles, nicht richtig.
Schnelles, symmetrisches Internet.
Wo ist Deutschland jetzt auf Platz 27, je nachdem wie man zählt, im Glasfaser ausbauen?
Ne, von unten nicht, von oben gezählt. Wir sind ganz unten.
Ihr macht ja irgendwie nicht so den Eindruck, als ob ihr zu wenig zu tun habt.
Jetzt auch noch das? Wollt ihr jetzt Internet-Millionär werden?
Ne, also das nicht. Ich wollte mich schon immer zur Ruhe setzen. Ne, genau genommen ja gar nicht. Aber das ist wieder so ein Ding, auch das ist ein Thema, dass ich bin ja recht viel in Schweden und wir betreiben da Infrastruktur in Schweden, haben ein kleines Rechenzentrum aufgebaut mit ein paar Leuten und so. Und die Frage ist, warum kann ich das hier nicht machen? Und die ganz einfache Antwort ist, dass es hier überhaupt keine Infrastruktur gibt und auch kein Ökosystem, dass es irgendwen wirklich erlauben würde, sehr niedrigschwellig Dienste im Internet aufzubauen oder sowas wie ein Rechenzentrum. Alle Leute, die ich kenne, sind ja auch hier ein paar im Raum. So das ist ein Kampf gegen Windmühlen irgendwie, wo man ständig gucken muss, wo man irgendwie bleibt. Und das ist in Schweden halt ganz anders. Und der einzige wirkliche Unterschied ist, dass es in Schweden an jeder Ecke eine Glasfaser gibt. Also eigentlich in fast allen Häusern. Und dass das als Grundlage für alle möglichen Ideen, die Menschen umtreiben, für Projekte, für Geflüchtete, die auf einmal irgendwo zu Hunderten geparkt werden, irgendwo, die ins Internet wollen und in Deutschland hier vielleicht eine 50 MBit DSL-Verbindung bekommen können oder sowas. Es skaliert ja auch überhaupt nicht. Es skaliert ja überhaupt nicht. Von daher haben wir dieses Thema irgendwann identifiziert, wenn man so will. Wir haben uns auch mit unserem Haus in Brandenburg schwer geärgert, dass wir ziemlich am verlierenden Ende dieser ganzen Angelegenheit sitzen.
Es gab da so ein Angebot von der Telekom. Zehn MBit symmetrisch für 500 Euro im Monat.
Na gut, aber das ist aber so, das ist vollkommen realistisch. Da braucht man auch nicht nur die Telekom zu fragen. Das ist ein Luxusgut, eine symmetrische Leitung zu bekommen. Das ist überhaupt nicht geplant. Ihr alle, die zuhört, ihr sollte überhaupt nichts zu sagen haben, weil ihr nur Download braucht, also Downstream. Das bisschen Upstream, das muss für alle reichen, weil man immer noch davon ausgeht, dass die Menschen ja gar nichts zu übermitteln haben. Das Wirtschaftsministerium hat gerade erklärt, dass wir schon symmetrische Leitungen brauchen in Industriegebieten. Das ist die Frage, wo passiert denn digitale Ökonomie? Die passiert nicht im Industriegebiet, in der Fabrik, sondern die passiert da, wo all die Leute, die hier zuhören, irgendwie zu Hause sind, weil die Ideen haben und die einfach von zu Hause eigentlich umsetzen können.
Ganz viele andere sind es ja auch noch. Unser Nachbar ist zum Beispiel Anwalt und Brandenburg ist eins der ersten Länder, das der Elektronische Gerichtsakte verpflichtend macht. Wer schon mal größere Akten gesehen hat, der hat jetzt schon total den Horror und sagt, er weiß gar nicht, wie das werden soll, wenn die dadurch diese Anschlüsse genudelt werden sollen, und zwar upstream, wie soll das funktionieren? Oder das sind irgendwelche MRT-Bilder, die sich Ärzte hin und her schicken wollen. Das ist ja gar nicht nur die Internetökonomie. Das sind E-Government-Geschichten. Und wie will ich denn Leute ausschließen von Bürgerbeteiligung online, wenn man sie denn mal haben sollte, wenn die da einfach keine vernünftigen Anwendungen haben? Also wie will man Bildung vernünftig machen für die Zukunft, wenn die Schulen sich keine anständigen Geschwindigkeiten leisten können, weil sie so eine komischen Angebote kriegen wie wir? Das geht einfach alles überhaupt nicht. Und insofern war das Unternehmensgründung aus purer Notwehr und Verzweiflung, aber auch, weil man das Vorbild in Schweden gesehen hat, wo man 100 Mbit symmetrisch für 30 Euro kriegt. Das ist das Zehnfache für einen Bruchteil.
Und wie macht man das? Also wie geht man hin, dass man sagt, okay, habt ihr jetzt einen Spaten und legt Glas rein?
Nee.
Also sag mal kurz, was jetzt sozusagen da systemisch in Schweden anders ist, dass das so gut funktioniert.
Also die Grundlage dafür war, dass in den 90er Jahren ein paar Leute sich nicht mit der Antwort zufriedengegeben haben, dass das mit der Glasfaser noch Zeit hat. Und sich überlegt haben, wie sieht die Wertschöpfungskette überhaupt aus? Und dann hat man festgestellt, dass die Kompetenzen, die man zum Beispiel braucht, um eine Glasfaser zu verlegen, ganz andere Kompetenzen sind als die, die man braucht, um jetzt eine Hotline zu betreiben, wo Endkunden sich melden, wenn ihr Internetanschluss nicht geht. Und so hat man diese Wertschöpfungskette aufgeteilt in vier verschiedene Bereiche. Also einmal unten die passive Infrastruktur, dann den Betrieb dieser passiven Infrastruktur, dann die Vermittlung der passiven Infrastruktur zu Diensten und die Dienste eben oben drüber. Und so gibt es eine Trennung dieser verschiedenen Zuständigkeiten. Und man hat gesagt, warum macht nicht jeder das, was er am besten kann? Infrastruktur ist eine Frage von Daseinsvorsorge. Die Frage, ob wir Breitband haben, ist ähnlich relevant wie die Frage danach, ob ich irgendwie einen Abwasseranschluss habe an meinem Haus. Das ist heute schon so und wird in Zukunft noch viel mehr so sein.
Was ist denn das?
Vielleicht so ein 120er Rohr oder sowas?
Es geht aber an üblicher Weise mehr raus als rein.
Es ist ja vollkommen abwegig, dass man jetzt einem kommerziellen Unternehmen den Abwasseranschluss überlassen würde. Das wäre vollkommener Quatsch. Der Markt regelt das schon irgendwie. Irgendeiner wird sich finden, der dir das da anbietet. Aber warum ist das bei der Infrastruktur, die wir gut verstehen, warum denken wir das irgendwie so anders?
Die liefern einfach was vollkommen Ausreichendes mit unserem Angebot. Können sie mindestens zweimal am Tag pinkeln und auch einmal die Woche...
Ja, genau.
Bis zu. Je nachdem, wie viele Leute da sind. Wenn der Nachbar da gerade halt viel getrunken hat, dann muss man mal gucken. Nee, aber um Spaß beiseite, um zurückzukommen. In Schweden hat man halt so gesagt, man teilt das irgendwie auf und der Ausbau von Infrastruktur, und das ist ja auch ein Problem, das wir hier haben, kann nicht funktionieren, wenn das ein Unternehmen oder eine Einheit irgendwie macht. Niemand kann für ganz Deutschland Glasfaser ausbauen. Aber wer hat das Interesse? Die Infrastruktur ist ein Interesse von der Community, in der man lebt, also in der Regel der Gemeinde oder der Stadt oder so. Also baut die Stadt, die eh tiefbauerische Kompetenzen hat, die Glasfaser aus. Jemand betreibt das Netz. Als Netzbetreiber kümmert sich darum, dass das nicht überbelegt ist, dass das ordentlich funktioniert. Und dann gibt es auf diesen Netzen Dienste, die angeboten werden können und das Ganze eben zu Konditionen, die für alle einfach gleich sind. Ein neutrales Netz. Das ist sehr nah dran an der Idee von Netzneutralität und von einem offenen Netz. Das ist ja auch hier nicht ganz neu, aber wir denken so noch gar nicht wirklich.
Wir reden bisher bei Netzneutralität immer nur über die Pakete, aber nicht über die Leitung.
Ja und im Endeffekt ist auch da ja dann die Frage, wenn Diensteanbieter einen neutralen Zugang haben zu diesem Netz, dann kann ich ja auch ein Diensteanbieter sein, der ein netzneutrales Netz mit, was die Pakete sich betreibt, das ist ja ein Alleinstellungsmerkmal unter Umständen, für das es in Deutschland einige Abnehmer gibt, nämlich eine Community, die sensibel ist für dieses Thema. Und was also in Schweden entstanden ist, um das kurz zu sagen, ist eine Plattform und das ist auch das, was wir hier für Deutschland machen wollen oder machen, was jetzt anläuft, ist eine Plattform, die quasi eine vermittelnde Schicht darstellt zwischen den Diensteanbietern und den vielen Netzen. Wir haben also zwei Drittel der Kommunen in Schweden, die ihre eigenen Netze ausgebaut haben, also das sind wirklich viele, und ganz viele Diensteanbieter, die in diesen Netzen ihre Dienste anbieten können, in so einer Art Many-to-Many-Ökosystem. Und die vereinheitlichte Schnittstelle in der Mitte stellt sicher, dass es für alle nicht besonders kompliziert ist, dass jetzt nicht jedes Netz mit jedem Diensteanbieter extra verhandeln muss, sondern dass das Ganze eben auch stark automatisiert werden kann. Und vor allem, dass es eine einheitliche, transparente Plattform ist, die für alle die gleichen Konditionen bietet.
Und das ist das, was ihr anbieten möchtet, oder was ihr schaffen möchtet?
Also wir wollen zwei Dinge. Einmal wollen wir, dass dieser Marktplatz benutzt wird, weil er die Basis ist für ein offenes, neutrales und flexibles Netz. In der Praxis heißt es, ich hab so eine Art Portal und wie im App Store kann ich sehen, wer mir da was anbietet. Ich kann also sehen, weiß eins und eins, hundert, hundert. Ich kann sehen, von mir aus, vielleicht Deutsch Telekom, wenn sie mitspielen.
Man zieht einen in die neue Wohnung, dann liegt da irgendwie so eine Internetdose, steckt mal in seinen Rechner rein, erste Seite so.
Ist dann dieses Eingangsportal. Genau, genau so. Transparent heißt, ich kann genau sehen, wer was anbietet. Ich muss nicht jede Woche einen anderen Flyer geschickt kriegen und durchlesen und seltsame Angebote vergleichen, sondern ich sehe vergleichbare Angebote und ich sehe die Konditionen dazu. Und das Schönste daneben steht Bindungsfrist Null. Das heißt, wenn es mir nicht gefällt, weg damit, dann klicke ich irgendwo, Software Defined Networking, Minute später habe ich wen anders. Diese Kombinationen aus transparente Angebote und maximale Flexibilität für den Nutzer führt zu einem sehr interessanten Wettbewerb. Allein das Anschalten dieses Marktplatzes hat in schwedischen Städten, wo die sowas haben, zu einem Preiseinbruch von 30 Prozent geführt und du hast am Ende einfach richtig geiles Internet. Schweden hat die schnellste Durchschnitts-Internet-Geschwindigkeit in Europa. Die viertst schnellste in der Welt und gleichzeitig ist es am preiswertesten. Das ist doch das, was man haben will. Schnell und billig.
Und das Ding ist, es ist halt machbar. Das ist halt das wichtige Take-Away. Es ist machbar, man muss nur eben anders denken. Und da sind wir wieder bei diesem ganzen größeren Thema von Digitalisierung. Wir müssen so viel in der Gesellschaft neu denken, weil das das ist, was die Digitalisierung mit sich bringt. Wir müssen alte Geschäftskonzepte eben halt auch irgendwann über Bord werfen. Und wenn wir sehen, was die Telekom im Moment veranstaltet und mit welchen Methoden man versucht, ein Geschäftssystem, das eigentlich nicht überlebensfähig ist, am Leben zu halten mit staatlichen Subventionen und wie viele Milliarden versenkt werden sollen in so eine tote Technologie wie Vectoring. Dann mit all den seltenen Erden, die da irgendwo verbaut werden und irgendwann wieder weggeschmissen werden können, mit dem Strom, den das Ganze verbraucht und mit diesen ganzen hässlichen grauen Kästen, die irgendwo aufgebaut werden müssen.
Und mit dem Biss zu da drin.
Ja, und dann muss man sich ja schon fragen, wieso ist es nicht an der Zeit, das jetzt einfach anders zu machen?
Es ist schade, dass du nicht wieso gefragt hast, weil das hätte ich dir gerne beantwortet. Ich habe nämlich auf dem Weg hierher eine Zeitung am Flughafen gelesen, stand drin, Bundesregierung stockt ihre Telekom-Aktien auf. Die Bundesregierung ist bereits größter Einzelaktionär der deutschen Telekom. Sie ist aber gleichzeitig diejenige, die die Regulierung macht und sagt, liebe Telekom, Vectoring finden wir super, wir schmeißen unsere ganzen Breitbandsubventionen in diese veraltete Technologie, wo alte Pferdekutschen mit elektrischem Pied schon angetrieben werden. Und wir sorgen dafür, dass du total viel Geschäft dafür machst, weil wir geben mir die Vorgaben vor, nach denen diese Subventionen vergeben werden. Und dann, wenn du den richtigen Remonopolisierung des Marktes hast und voll viel Geschäft, dann haben wir was davon, weil wir sind ja jetzt Aktionär. Die sind also Eigentümer, Regulierer und Einkäufer. Sind sie auch noch, was in einem privatwirtschaftlichen Umfeld wahrscheinlich längst die Monopolkommission offen planbringen würde. Aber hier passiert es einfach und leider passiert es auf Kosten der gesamten Gesellschaft, die deshalb den Anschluss an die digitale Entwicklung völlig verpasst. Wir haben 2,2 Prozent Anteil Glasfaseranschlüsse an den Gesamtbreitbandanschlüssen. Das ist der Horror. Und diese Förderungsstrategie der Bundesregierung hat dazu geführt, dass die Deutsche Telekom in diesem Jahr so wenig ausgebaut hat in Glasfaser-to-the-home-Anschlüssen wie das letzte Mal 2011. Noch 2014 war es doppelt so viel wie in diesem Jahr. Warum? Die Strategie macht, dass es weniger wird und nicht mehr. Also hirnverbrannter kann man Politik eigentlich nicht machen.
Und ich habe hier die Vermutung, dass die Telekom darauf hofft, den Physiknobelpreis demnächst abzuräumen, weil sie nachweisen können, dass Kupfer ja Glasfaser ist.
Sie kriegen den Physiknobelpreis für die Erfindung der Bit-Sekunde. Kennst du die Bit-Sekunde? Ja, ich hab ein Plakat gesehen von der deutschen Telekom. Da gibt es also bis zu, ist klar, ne? Bis zu 100 M pro Bit-Sekunde. Also M slash Bit. Ich weiß nicht, wie viele Bs man da durchgibt, aber 100 M pro Bit-Sekunde. Das müsst ihr erstmal schaffen.
Ja, das müssen wir erstmal schaffen.
Ja, also der CCC ist ja in den 80er Jahren, weil er der Hauptfeind auch immer schon, der Gelb. Ich weiß nicht genau, wie man aus der Farbe Magenta was Passendes schmieden kann, aber irgendwie hat sich nichts geändert. Also es ist sozusagen immer noch dasselbe Problem.
Die Deutsche Telekom ist ein Schwein mit Lippenstift.
Um vielleicht noch mal einen Punkt aber auch zu sagen, ein bisschen ist ja die Frage und die müssen wir uns stellen, selbst wenn die Telekom ausbauen würde, wenn wir alle verstehen, wie die Anforderungen an die Infrastruktur in Zukunft sein werden und wie wichtig eine funktionierende Infrastruktur ist, in wessen Händen ist diese Infrastruktur am besten aufgehoben. Und ich glaube, selbst wenn die Telekom alles ausbauen würde heute und wir wären einigermaßen zufrieden damit, weil es kein Vectoring wäre oder so, sind wir trotzdem, dann wären wir für immer abhängig davon, was die Telekom adäquat findet an Produkten, die auf diesen Netzen bereitgestellt werden oder auch nicht. Und ich möchte ehrlich gesagt überhaupt nicht, dass es ein privatwirtschaftliches Unternehmen ist, das mir zugesteht, wie viel Abwasser durch meine Abwasserleitung pro Tag so durch darf. Sondern ich glaube, dass das, was ist, was idealerweise meine eigene Entscheidung sein sollte und ich glaube, dass die Stadt, in der ich lebe, die viel besser versteht, was ich brauche, dass die einfach da mehr auf meiner Seite ist, als ein privatwirtschaftliches Unternehmen. Wenn man also ein Modell machen kann, in dem diese Infrastruktur wieder zurückkommt in die öffentlichen Hände und in dem auch Profite, und das funktioniert ja in Schweden auch, in denen Profite auch zu 50 Prozent etwa jeden Monat für jeden Internetanschluss, der in diese Infrastruktur geschaltet ist, zurückfließen an die Kommunen und damit der Netzausbau bezahlt wird und man innerhalb von sagen wir 8 bis 12 Jahren oder so dieses Netz refinanziert hat bei 30 Jahren, die das vielleicht wartungsfrei bleibt oder noch ein bisschen länger, dann heißt das, dass wir extrem viel Geld jeden Monat, jeder einzelne von uns, von unserem Internetanschluss an die Kommunen geben, in der wir leben und diese Kommunen das Geld nehmen können, um es in Bildung zu investieren, in Kindergärten, in Schulen und in alle möglichen anderen Dinge, die für unsere Gemeinschaft, in der wir leben, Sinn machen und halt nicht für irgendwelche Aktionäre, die irgendwo rum sitzen und eine Rendite erwarten. Und ich glaube, dass auch diese andere Perspektive nicht vernachlässigt werden darf, sondern ganz im Gegenteil total wichtig ist und dass eine viel gesündere Welt wäre, als das in die Situation, in der wir uns heute befinden.
Ich sag mal Amen Netz.
Man traut sich kaum noch was danach zu sagen.
Super Abschluss. Daniel.
Danke.
Vielen Dank.
Ja danke auch.
Danke.
Da stelle ich noch mal kurz an den Einen.
Warte. Ein Terabyte.
Durch welche Leitung denn?
Eher wahrscheinlich über 600 im Livestream. Macht ihr noch ein bisschen.
Was sollen wir denn noch machen jetzt?
Okay, halt mal an.
Man kann ja sonst nix.
Wir machen das Terabyte noch voll.
Es wäre natürlich ärgerlich, das Terabyte jetzt nicht zu schaffen. Da muss uns jetzt noch irgendwas einfallen, weil eigentlich sind wir jetzt so langsam in Richtung Ende der Sendung.
Ja, haben wir denn überhaupt schon... Zwei Stunden haben wir schon voll hier. Hat sich schon jemand auf Twitter beschwert, dass er so viel sitzen muss. Normalerweise joggt ihr ja mal alle, ihr Gutgestellten. Ja Linus...
Könnt ihr die Katze noch ein bisschen filmen?
Jetzt haben wir noch gar nicht... Müssen wir jetzt vielleicht auch nicht viel drüber reden, aber so, jetzt haben wir irgendwie auch echt fünf Jahre durch. Hätte ich jetzt auch nicht unbedingt gedacht, muss ich sagen. Also ich hab ja mal, ich bin ja ein bisschen schuld, muss ich sagen. Ich hab bei den Linus mal so angehauen.
Camp 2011.
Camp 2011, da dachte ich mir so, der Linus und so, der weiß ja was, ne? Und ich weiß ja eigentlich nicht so viel, aber reden kann ich. Also dachte ich mir, wäre das vielleicht eine ganz gute Kombi. Hat ganz gut gehalten.
Ja, wird auch weitergehen, wenn die uns die Themen nicht wegnehmen.
Du meinst, wenn auf einmal alles gut wird?
Ja gut oder alles schlecht, das ist ein bisschen die Sorge. Ich bin ja nicht so, also ich muss ja auch sagen, so was mit Live-Sendung, ich hab dem Tim ja irgendwie Druck gemacht, ich will eine Live-Sendung, wir haben 200 Jahre Netzpolitik und so. Eigentlich ist das überhaupt nicht meine Welt, deswegen bin ich super froh, dass wir so viele Gäste hatten, die für uns hier die Sendung gestaltet haben. Und ich weiß gar nicht genau, wie ich... Also ich hätte nicht damit gerechnet... Also wenn ich diese Sendung geplant hätte, ohne Tim, dann hätten wir, weiß nicht, mit 50 Leuten irgendwo in irgendeinem Konferenzsaal gesessen, weil ich nicht damit gerechnet hätte, dass mehr Leute kommen würden. Tim hingegen läuft natürlich dann so irgendwie in so einen Laden rein, wie so... Wie viele passen denn hier rein, das sieht ein bisschen stickig aus. Und so haben wir es dann doch irgendwie geschafft, diesen schönen Abend auf die Beine zu stellen. Ist das Terabyte schon voll jetzt? Peter, immer noch nicht. Wie viel müssen wir denn noch? Wie viel Abwasser muss noch durch die Leitung?
Ja, nee, aber hat doch ganz gut funktioniert, finde ich super.
Schau mal Tim, was könnte das denn sein?
Kein Schlüsselwort, da diest ein Schlüssel jetzt, nimm mir den endlich ab, verdammt.
Das ist unser neuer Internetanschluss.
Jetzt hab ich hier schon irgendwie...
Du hast alles voll mit Flaschen gestellt, da kommt man gar nicht mehr durch.
Auf Getränk hab ich ihn gebracht, das hab ich jetzt auch falsch gemacht. Was ist jetzt mit dem Schlüssel, das geht doch weiter.
Ich hab den Schlüssel, was ist denn das?
Da steht was drauf, versteh ich aber nicht.
Was ist denn das jetzt hier für ein Spiel? Er ist kein Spiel, there is no game.
Was sollen wir damit machen?
Und irgendwie mit ein Zeichen.
Was ist das? Jeder Topf hat einen Deckel, jeder Schlüssel hat sein, verfolgt sind die die, sind satt, sind selbstständig.
Bart, dieser Schlüssel hat einen Bart.
Ja, du hast auch einen schönen Bart.
Hab ich, ich erkenne einen Schloss. Soll ich den da reinstecken?
Nein, lass lieber sein, die Leute wollen noch hierbleiben und wir müssen das ganze Fernarbeit noch vollkriegen.
Falsch rum?
Jetzt. Und? Zack. Und jetzt?
Aber es gibt kein Spiel, deswegen machen wir einfach weiter. Damit wären wir am Ende der Sendung. Doch.
Der Epilog steht an, ihr kennt das.
Da gab es einen langen Streit über das Epilog, weil der Epilog, den ich immer wieder Intro nenne in den Show Notes, wird relativ lange gehen heute.
Ja, gibt einiges zu bedanken.
Trink noch mal einen Schluck. Du während du trinkst, ich danke der Fiona.
Ich danke der Verena.
Und ich danke Tobi und Roland.
Ich danke dem tollen Videoteam, was hier streamt und aufzeichnet, Peter, Danimo und Mo an der Kamera.
Und wir danken natürlich dem Vorverkaufsteam Rami und Rix, die einen super schönen Vorverkauf für euch gemacht haben. Hoffentlich kriegen wir auch das Geld davon.
Am Eingang freundlich empfangen und betreut haben euch Cebas, Hausi und Jan.
Vielen Dank dafür.
Danke.
Wat?
Megabyte? M pro Bit-Sekunde.
Ja, wir zögern es noch ein bisschen raus.
Wir streamen einfach nachher noch den DJ mit und dann passt das. Wo waren wir denn jetzt? Den Leuten, die immer dabei sind und unterstützen, insbesondere Papillon und Arne Bense.
Genau.
Und?
Und der Jan, der heute hier Fotos gemacht hat. Und dann danken wir natürlich vor allem auch den ganz konkreten Bühnenmitstreitern, insbesondere natürlich Nikolas und Reinhard von Methodisch inkorrekt für die tolle Show. Und natürlich den Gästen, wie zum Beispiel Raiq Anders.
Der Maria Reimer.
Judith Horchardt.
Und Anke Domscheit-Berg.
Und natürlich auch Daniel Domscheit-Berg.
Und natürlich auch Dat Henning.
Dat Henning, unser Super Moderator-Assistentin. Genau. Denn Sven, die, wie die immer super Grafik macht, der Florian Erbeck, der uns diese tollen Intros jetzt auch in Moll besorgt. Ich danke auch nochmal persönlich hier dem Sendezentrum-Team, was mich so in den letzten Jahren so oft begleitet hat und mir immer den Rücken freigehalten hat, Ralf, Claudia und Dennis. So, dann haben wir den Martin noch vergessen, vorhin beim Audio- und Video-Setup, den haben wir auch dabei.
Und dann kommen wir in die etwas generelleren Ecken. Wir danken natürlich netzpolitik.org und die Redaktion ist inzwischen so groß, dass es nicht mehr geht, allen einzeln zu danken, aber natürlich André Meister, Markus, Markus und Anna.
Besondere ehrenvolle Erwähnung natürlich auch für Thomas Lohninger, der sich einen Kopf-an-Kopf-Rennen mit Andrej Meister liefert, als häufigster Linus-Ersatz in dieser Sendung. Ja, aber auch super Netzneutralitätssieger ist des Jahres.
Dann möchte ich noch persönlich danken, Pepe und Daniela, Heinz und Anna-Rita, Daniel und Lisa, dem Chat, den es nicht gibt, John F. Nebel und Kalle Kornblumen.
Genau. Und natürlich auch ein dauerhafter Themengeber, natürlich auch das Team von Heise Online. Und wir würden jetzt auch gerne alle Spender hier aufzählen, aber die Liste ist viel zu lang und insofern pauschal. Jeder, der uns hier auch finanziell unterstützt hat in den letzten Jahren, ist natürlich ganz in unserem Herzen. Alle Sendungsgäste, die wir da hatten, zahlreich, die können wir jetzt nicht alle aufzählen. Natürlich alle Besucher heute Abend, alle Leute, die live im Stream dazu geschaltet haben, alle Hackspaces, die Logbuch Netzpolitik heute auch noch kollektiv sich anschauen. Da ist so einiges passiert, habe ich auch erst am Rande mitbekommen. Vielen, vielen Dank.
Das war's.
Logbuch Netzpolitik 200. Super, dass ihr alle da wart. Und wir hoffen, dass es irgendwann nochmal was Ähnliches geben kann.